rendez-vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure vous a été présenté
par écho DDS éco-organisme qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour à tous il est 9h30 nous sommes
en direct sur l'antenne de public Sana
pour suivre l'examen de la réforme des
retraites ici à la Chambre haute du
Parlement avec vous le voyez une
programmation spéciale sur Public Sénat
les soirs les week-ends
et heure par heure alors où en
sommes-nous dans cette réforme des
retraites au Sénat elle est examinée en
séance depuis jeudi après-midi hier les
sénateurs et sénatrices ont démarré vers
18h l'examen des articles et amendement
du texte il reste d'ailleurs à l'heure
où je vous parle très précisément 3000
653 amendements examinés d'ici au 12
mars et la séance reprend dans quelques
minutes à 9h35 pour en parler on va
rejoindre notre journaliste Mathias Saez
bonjour Mathias vous allez m'accompagner
toute la journée dans ce direct du Sénat
dites-nous un petit peu comment ça s'est
passé hier bonjour Quentin bonjour à
tous hier soir dans l'hémicycle nous
avons assisté à une multitude et une
succession de prise de parole des trois
groupes de gauche pour dénoncer
l'article liminaire entre 17h et minuit
30 77 amendements ont été examinés un
rythme de croisière me direz-vous les LR
eux ont pris leur mal en patience
prenant la parole moins de 10 fois au
total une bataille qui a parfois mis les
nerfs à vif à l'image du sénateur LR de
Haute-Marne bruno Sido
comme en train à cette heure-ci de
donner de la même impression que le
peuple français retient de l'Assemblée
nationale
ainsi à ceux-ci près
non attendez attendez à ceci près j'ai
entendu un journaliste tout à l'heure
dans la salle des conférences faire ses
observations et nous dire que finalement
ici au Sénat c'était l'obstruction
cordiale
je trouve que le mot était bien choisi
vous l'avez peut-être entendu cette
intervention a suscité une bronca dans
les rangs de la gauche avec plusieurs
réponses et notamment celles du
socialiste Yann chanterel sénateur
représentant les Français établis hors
de France
vous auriez honneur justement à
intervenir dans ce débat nous avons
entendu une seule prise de parole mais
intervenez c'est votre effort défendez
là justifiez là argumentez c'est ça le
Parlement c'est pas de se taire c'est
pas d'avoir un bâillon retaillant sur la
bouche c'est de pouvoir intervenir
défendre vos arguments faites comme
Monsieur Pradier lui au moins il a
défendu des choses contrairement à vous
elle est où l'époque elle est où
l'époque de la droite sociale Gauliste
des échanges dans la longueur jusqu'à
minuit 30 donc qui ont tout de même
permis au Sénat d'adopter l'article
liminaire avant de s'arrêter et ce matin
et bien c'est l'article 1 qui est au
menu Quentin merci beaucoup Mathias pour
toutes ces explications pour en parler
j'accueille ici vraiment de penser vous
êtes sénatrice écologiste du Rhône et
vous êtes la chef de fil des écologistes
sur ce texte un mot sur ce qui s'est
joué en séance hier rapidement et
effectivement cette obstruction cordiale
de la gauche vous êtes d'accord
écoutez moi je remarque aussi
l'obstruction silencieuse mutique de la
droite du Sénat qui est en fin de compte
ne dit rien donc je comprends bien que
on ne disant rien elle accélère l'examen
de la loi par contre moi j'invite les
Français à aller écouter les
interventions d'hier nous nous sommes
intervenus trois fois sur l'article
criminaire trois fois en disant des
choses différentes donc à chaque fois
les arguments sur le fond c'est ça sur
le fond et développer de façon
différente par chacun des des
contributeurs
dans quelques instants et votre
stratégie vous allez déposer une motion
oui pour renvoyer en commission
l'article 1 sur les régimes spéciaux
parce que j'estime que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment parlé de quelque chose de
leur suppression qui est importante et
notamment moi ce n'est pas encore eu le
temps de voir en quoi c'était des
privilégiés et bien merci vraiment de
penser
immédiatement pour que vous puissiez
rejoindre l'hémicycle on va écouter tous
ces échanges dans un instant dans
l'hémicycle mais d'abord on va retrouver
Mathias sarez un aux yeux nos oreilles
dans l'hémicycle toute cette journée et
de quoi s'agit-il que va-t-il se passer
maintenant Mathias on rentre dans le dur
quand un ce matin ça y est l'article 1
va être débattu mais avant même qu'un
seul amendement ne soit examiné déjà 16
orateurs ont demandé à prendre la parole
en plus de la motion que vous évoquez à
l'instant il semblerait donc que l'on
reparte sur les mêmes bases qu'hier en
ce troisième jour de débat du texte de
la réforme des retraites et aujourd'hui
Quentin pas moins de 356 amendements
sont prévus pour rappel l'article 1er
c'est l'article qui vise à supprimer les
régimes spéciaux 5 au total notamment
ceux de la RATP des salariés des
industries du gaz et de l'électricité ou
encore ceux d'éclairs de notaire et des
salariés de la Banque de France un débat
qui trouve déjà écho dans l'actualité
puisqu'il hier les syndicats des
électriciens et gaziers ont entamé une
reconductible pour coller au calendrier
de l'examen de cet article au Sénat un
article qui tient particulièrement à
coeur à la droite sénatoriale qui veut
accélérer ses suppressions en allant
même plus loin que le gouvernement les
LR du Palais du Luxembourg ne souhaitant
pas de clause du grand-père Quentin oui
merci Mathias et donc on va se diriger
vers l'hémicycle pour écouter ces
échanges autour de l'article 1 donc sur
les régimes spéciaux et vous l'avez vu
c'est Roger caoutchi premier
vice-président LR du Sénat qui préside
la séance direction l'hémicycle
renvoie en commission de l'article
premier
sur cette notion d'envoi madame vraiment
de penser manger le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire en déposé une
motion 47 38 tendant au renvoie à la
Commission de l'article liminaire la
parole est à Madame Raymonde pensée
mange pour la motion
merci monsieur le président
Kio ou autonome en réalité les régimes
spéciaux ne concerne pas l'ensemble des
salariés de ces branches mais uniquement
ceux qui ont les conditions de travail
les plus dures pour la RATP les
conducteurs et mainteneurs représentent
31000 personnes sur 45000 pour
l'ensemble du pays en 2019 les retraités
recevant une pension des régimes
spéciaux était de 6% environ
de l'ensemble de nos retraités mettre
fin au régime spéciaux et autonome sous
prétexte d'équité supposer universalité
est une diversion pour faire oublier que
tout le monde va pâtir du report de
l'âge légal les régimes d'df et de la
RATP par exemple prévoit de meilleures
anticipations de départ et une meilleure
prise en compte de la pénibilité car
c'est travailleurs sont exposés à des
facteurs de pénibilité décrit dans des
tableaux bien détaillés et des risques
donc d'incapacité importante après 17
ans de catégorie active et donc
d'exposition à ces risques à cette
pénalité ils peuvent partir à 57 ans et
demain à 59 ans nous n'avons pas eu le
temps de débusquer en quoi c'était des
privilégiés la justice sociale et
l'équité serait juste d'appliquer ces
mesures sérieuses de prise en compte de
la pénibilité à tous et à tous les
travailleurs accomplissant les travaux
pénibles plutôt que de niveler par le
bas et comme eux de prévenir avant de
réparer je précise quand au déroulait
des discussions des gens qui ont lieu en
commission à huis clos son captation
vidéo sans avoir le temps de nous
exprimer sur tous les amendements donc
au-delà du recours abusif à l'article
47.1 de l'attente lancinante de la note
du Conseil d'État tous les soucis que
posent ce texte et de manière et la
manière dont le débat est muselé vous
serez bien obligé de reconnaître que
nous avons un vrai problème démocratique
le groupe écologique estime donc que le
sujet ce sujet des régimes spéciaux son
impact sur la vie de milieu de
travailleurs mérite d'être au préalable
largement plus débattu en commission
merci
quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur général oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
Istres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales chers
collègues Madame Raymonde poncemont je
demande un retour finalement du débat en
commission il me semble que vous étiez
en commission madame Raymond ponce que
vous avez pu vous exprimer un certain
nombre de vos collègues se sont exprimés
est-ce que cette finalement une demande
de rattrapage pour ceux qui n'étaient
pas là je me pose la question en
l'occurrence nous avons eu des heures et
des heures d'audition et nous avons reçu
l'ensemble de ces régimes spéciaux nous
avons d'ailleurs pu leur poser un
certain nombre de questions vous y étiez
pour certains je pense que vous avez eu
vos réponses donc un retour en
commission c'est non
très bien avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur mais madame la
vie et Mesdames et la vie du
gouvernement est évidemment défavorable
les auditions ont eu lieu ça a été dit
mais au-delà des auditions cette
question des régions spéciaux n'est pas
une question nouvelle dans le paysage
politique et je crois que année projet
de loi de lancement la sécurité sociale
après le projet de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour ce qui concerne
votre assemblée ce sujet est amplement
débattu nous savons que ces régimes ont
été créés un moment où ils pouvaient
sembler nécessaire mais qu'aujourd'hui
les différences qu'ils ont par rapport
au régime général ne justifient plus ne
justifie plus par l'évolution des
conditions de travail de ses propres
régimes et se justifier encore moins
quand on compare avec les conditions de
travail les conditions d'exercice de
salariés affiner région général qui
exercent les mêmes tâches les mêmes
métiers avec les mêmes objectifs donc la
vie est défavorable car il est un avancé
merci Monsieur le Ministre une
explication de votre possible par groupe
il n'y a pas d'obligation
Madame A pour ce polype
merci monsieur le Président en 2019 le
gouvernement avait qualifié les régimes
spéciaux de privilèges pour diviser les
Français et faire passer la retraite à
points c'est un compte de vous entendre
d'aujourd'hui vanter le régime par
répartition alors que vous vouliez la
battre il y a à peine 4 ans vous
entendez mettre fin au régime spéciaux
sous prétexte de renforcer la justice
sociale entre les futurs retraités vous
allez plus loin vous proposer des
mesures plus dures que nous l'avez fait
Nicolas Sarkozy en son temps les régimes
spéciaux accorde des compensations à des
travailleurs sans des métiers pénibles
qui existent
qui exige des astreintes fréquentes et
entraînent une usure physique nous nous
opposons à leur suppression injuste il
faudrait que vous nous expliquiez pour
quelle raison ces métiers ne nécessitent
pas de mesures spécifiques d'aménagement
des carrières la possibilité d'anticiper
les départs en retraite pour mieux
prendre en compte la pénibilité car dans
ces secteurs les travailleurs ont une
espérance de vie souvent inférieure à la
moyenne des salariés nous souhaitons le
maintien du modèle social actuel les
régimes spéciaux ne sont pas des
privilèges Ambroise Croizat par les
d'ailleurs de conquis sociaux au lieu de
fermer le régime de la RATP des
électriciens et des gaziers de la Banque
de France du CESU et des clercs de nos
terres il faudrait généraliser ses
compensations à l'ensemble des
travailleurs qui accomplissent des
travaux pénibles notre groupe souhaite
supprimer cet article qui ferme des
régimes spéciaux fondés sur la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité du
travail pour cette raison notre groupe
votera la motion de renvoi en commission
déposée par nos collègues verts et
Monsieur le Ministre une fois de plus
nous vous demandons l'avis du Conseil
d'État que vous nous cachez depuis le
début soigneusement
et bien madame pomirol
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les régimes spéciaux
constituent selon vous des privilèges or
sont des régimes qui ont été pionniers
en matière de droit à la retraite et qui
ont été mis en place en raison de
l'organisation et de la nature du
travail dans ces différents secteurs et
ils sont le fruit d'une véritable
conquête sociale qui s'est construite au
formules des décennies de notre histoire
et ces régimes fonctionnent sur la base
d'une solidarité restreinte à une
profession
vous voulez supprimer ces mots
soi-disant privilège alors que
nous sommes pas des privilèges mais il
semble reconnaissances de la pénibilité
de leur travail et il mérite pourtant
une attention génétique mérite pourtant
une attention particulière ce régime a
été construit et négocié pour compenser
les nuisances qui leur sont inhérentes
nous sommes convaincus nous que
l'ensemble des salariés explosé à la
pénibilité doivent partir plutôt à la
retraite sans organiser un régime
favorable la reconnaissance de la
pénibilité l'équité doit être construite
davantage à davantage de droits et à une
meilleure qualité de travail pour
limiter difficile y compris ce qui
bénéfique c'est de régime dit spéciaux
et d'ailleurs j'aimerais que vous
puissiez nous expliquer monsieur le
ministre pourquoi seuls cinq régimes
parmi ton ensemble des régimes spéciaux
sont touchés par votre réforme et pas
les autres comment avez-vous fait le tri
je pense que vous lui expliquerez tout à
l'heure
ce fait de revenir et de niveler par le
bas risque de nuire à l'attractivité de
ses professions et donc nous sommes
favorables à un retour en commission
pour pouvoir étudier un peu mieux les
caractéristiques de ce métier merci
Madame poncemonge
le président alors monsieur le ministre
vous avez raison il y a des gens dans le
régime général surtout quand on
privatise les services publics ou qu'on
embauche simplement au
contractualisation qui ont les mêmes
conditions de travail vous prenez un
conducteur de bus RATP il est souvent je
sais pas pourquoi il est souvent cité là
vous avez un problème avec les
conducteurs de bus CRTP et effectivement
un conducteur d'un quart Macron
effectivement la pénibilité est
identique pas les salaires parce que
c'est pour ça que vous privatisez mais
la pénibilité en termes d'exposition au
facteurs de pénibilité entre un
conducteur de bus RATP et un conducteur
de vos Carmes Macron effectivement c'est
la même proposé vous proposez que le
conducteur de bus est RATP soit comme
celui de des karma des car Macron
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne parle qu'à 64 ans
mais avant s'il est cassé ah oui s'il
est cassé ou si bénéficie de
licenciement pour inaptitude il peut
partir avant et bien vous voyez les
régimes spéciaux ils sont préventifs
c'est à dire qu'il n'attendent pas que
les gens soient cassés pour leur
permettre de partir à 59 ans ou à 57 ils
sont effectivement c'est une exposition
c'est une présomption c'est une
présomption que ces facteurs de
pénibilité altèrent leur espérance de
vie et quand tu es au karmacron et bien
à 64 ans ou à 63 ans irrépareront à
défaut d'avoir prévenu
bien bien je suis saisi société de notre
demande non très bien je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe écologiste sur l'ensemble de la
motion je vous rappelle que la ville de
la commission est défavorable la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par la télé
sur l'antenne de public c'est na nous
sommes en direct vous voyez il y a un
scrutin public sur cette demande de
renvoi en commission et on le comprend
avec ce scrutin public mais aussi avec
les explications de vote ou encore donc
cette demande de renvoi en commission la
gauche utilise toutes les armes
disponibles au Règlement du Sénat pour
et bien se s'opposer et ralentir
l'examen de la réforme des retraites et
on voit aussi que il y a une différence
de ton avec l'Assemblée nationale
puisque toutes ces remarques se font
toujours sur le fond de la réforme donc
il y a un scrutin public ça signifie que
et bien on va avoir une cartographie du
vote de tous les sénateurs euh de de du
Sénat et qu'effectivement les sénateurs
votent non pas à main levée mais avec
des cartes électroniques de vote donc
vous voyez il y a un huissier qui est en
train de comme cela et bien vérifier que
plus personne ne demande à voter et
ensuite on va avoir le résultat sur les
340 sénateurs qui peuvent exprimer un
vote et donc c'est le tout premier
scrutin public de cette séance on
retourne dans l'hémicycle pour écouter
et bien le résultat de ce scrutin
votre temps 343 exprimer 342 pour 91
contre 251 la motion n'est pas adoptée
je passe donc à l'article premier et
j'ai déjà une trentaine de demandes de
prise de parole donc on va faire ça avec
ordre méthode pour deux minutes chacun
et chacun veillera à ne pas dépasser les
deux minutes
monsieur Fabien gay sera le premier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'histoire
sociale de notre pays est faite de lutte
de gains sociaux mal nommés acquis
sociaux plutôt conquis puisque on peut
et vous voulez y revenir la question de
l'égalité la justice sociale c'est
toujours fait par le haut et non en
tirant le droit des travailleurs et des
travailleurs par le bas la question des
régimes spéciaux qui est acquis aussi
avec le statut compte tenu de la
pénibilité de travail des cheminots des
traminaux des gaziers électriciens et de
dans d'autres d'ailleurs nous ne
connaissons aucun privilégié chez eux ni
milliardaire ce sont des hommes et des
femmes qui chaque jour assurent une
mission de service public dans des
conditions difficiles et c'était des
régimes pionniers qui avaient vocation à
s'étendre à l'ensemble des travailleurs
et des travailleurs
alors moi en ce début de premier article
j'ai une question à poser à la droite
sénatoriale nous ne sommes pas d'accord
sur la question des retraites mais nous
pouvons nous mettre d'accord par exemple
sur la question énergétique
et nous allons avoir à voter la création
de 8 nouveaux EPR très bien mais comment
vous allez faire en cassant le statut et
notamment ses régimes spéciaux qui
protègent leur sécurité et la nôtre mais
qui est surtout un élément
d'attractivité de la filière alors au
moment même où déjà nous cherchons des
ingénieurs ou aussi des soudeurs et tous
les métiers du nucléaire quel signal
vous allez envoyer aujourd'hui en
cassant le régime spécial des Ig qui
d'ailleurs est bénéficiaires et permet
au régime général de s'équilibrer parce
que en 20 ans ils ont versé trois fois
au régime général je vous pose cette
question et si vous y répondez on
continuera le débat je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président Laurent
[Applaudissements]
sur cet article que nous allons discuter
sur les régimes improprement appelés
régime spéciaux il faut être clair il ne
s'agit pas d'une question financière
parce que les gains de la suppression de
ces régimes seront pinotes par rapport
au problème dont on parle il ne s'agit
pas d'une question de justice sociale
puisque on ne fait jamais de justice
sociale en tirant quelques dizaines de
milliers de travailleurs supplémentaires
vers le bas la vérité c'est que on
s'attaquant à ces régimes spéciaux vous
voulez continuer à démanteler des
services publics dont nous avons
absolument besoin pour relever le pays
et le sortir de la crise actuelle
d'ailleurs dans les secteurs concernés
la construction des statues et le gain
de ces statuts on fait partie du contrat
pour construire le service public
ferroviaire dans le domaine des
cheminots et pour construire le système
électrique français comme l'a dit public
comme l'a dit mon collègue Fabien gay et
plus loin dans cette voie de suppression
vous allez envoyer un signal désastreux
nous en reparlerons tout à l'heure mais
à la RATP on cherche 4000 postes à
pourvoir et vous le signal que vous
allez envoyer à Monsieur Castex par
exemple pour lui faciliter la tâche pour
recruter ces 4000 personnes c'est que
les conditions de travail de ce qu'on
embauchera demain seront encore dégradés
par rapport aujourd'hui alors qu'on ne
trouve pas d'emploi à pourvoir à cause
de la dégradation des conditions de
travail de tous les métiers de la RATP
il manquait je vois mon collègue
Jean-François Rapin en face de moi il
manquait 300 conducteurs pour les TER en
haut de France au mois d'août comment
vous allez les trouver en envoyant comme
signal que nous allons continuer à
dégrader la condition de ces
travailleurs-là voilà la question qui
est posée donc ça n'est pas une question
de justice vous allez porter un coup aux
capacités de reconstruction de nos
services publics dont nous avons besoin
pour la transition écologique pour rien
mais réalisation du pays merci Madame
linman
[Applaudissements]
je vais prendre un exemple qui est
rarement cité celui des clairs de
notaire on sent que l'avenir du pays
dépend du statut de retraite des clercs
de notaire
il se trouve que la le régime de
retraite des clercs de notaire ne coûte
pas un centime à l'État et à jamais eu
la moindre subvention d'équilibre
deuxièmement c'est un régime assez
spécial gérer de façon paritaire avec un
accord entre les patrons les notaires
elle est claire de nos terres
alors franchement d'habitude vous vous
souvenez les patrons et ben là les
patrons ils demandent le maintien du
système le taux de cotisation est élevé
mais il est vrai aussi que c'est ça un
régime intégré c'est à dire c'est un
régime où vous avez à la fois la
retraite de base elle est retraites
complémentaires
très savoir au nom de quoi
en quoi ça fait progresser l'égalité
républicaine de s'attaquer à ce système
d'autant plus que même pour clair de
notaire et bien la profession n'est pas
hyper attractive si bien qu'il y a des
milliers de postes aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas pourvus et je rappelle que par
ailleurs les notaires sont présents sur
tout le territoire national
donc franchement
à part une vision idéologique de
l'égalité par le nivellement par le bas
c'est à dire la toise pour tout le monde
en réduisant parce que si par malheur le
progrès dans un secteur amenait les
autres salariés à revendiquer des choses
comparables vous rendez compte du
désastre
la réalité c'est que vous n'avez de
cesse de fragiliser le salariat
d'enlever des statues d'enlever des les
avantages potentiels parce que quand
même pas non plus le Pérou avec notre
mesure ils vont quand même perdre 25% de
la du taux de réversion de leur de leur
pension on va donc
merci Madame Linde la parole est à
Madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président voici revenu
le vieux débat de la suppression des
régimes spéciaux la droite en rêve
depuis qu'ils existent et c'est un
gouvernement ni de droite ni de gauche
mais surtout ni de gauche qui menace de
le faire quel intérêt de supprimer des
régimes des régimes autonomes tels que
celui des gaziers et celui des clercs de
nos terres qui ne demande rien à
personne
quel intérêt de vouloir rompre un
contrat avec des agents de catégories
actifs de la RF de la RATP qui de toute
façon ne prennent pas leur retraite à 52
ans mais quatre à cinq ans plus tard au
minimum
quel intérêt de verser au régime général
des milliers de salariés qui viendront
finalement creuser le déficit s'il doit
y en avoir un puisque vous nous annoncez
des déficits abyssaux
[Musique]
les les moyens contre les plus modestes
ou vice-versa merci merci Madame Brulin
merci monsieur le Président avec cet
article 1 qui vise à l'extinction de 5
régimes spéciaux vous voulez faire de
ceci le symbole qui serait censé
incarner la prétendue justice de votre
réforme en mettant fin au privilège
inconsidéré d'une toute petite minorité
qui se gaverait au détriment de la
grande majorité des salariés quelle est
la réalité de ces régimes en France il y
a 6,8 millions de cotisants qui
bénéficient d'un régime de base qui
n'est pas le régime général
8,6 millions de retraités qui bénéfient
d'un régime de base qui n'est pas le
régime général c'est à dire presque 1
sur 2 600 000 personnes en invalidé des
qui bénéficient d'un régime général qui
n'est pas le régime de base et
finalement ce sont près de 40% des
assurés sociaux qui bénéficient d'un
régime différent hors fonctionnaires
d'État parce que la réalité de la
situation des retraites et le fruit
d'une histoire des différentes caisses
de retraite c'est le fruit de conquête
sociale cela a été rappelé c'est le
fruit de négociation des différentes
conventions collectives là vous visez
moins de 1% des de la population active
que vous pointez comme des boucs
émissaires qui seraient aujourd'hui à
l'origine de tous les mots ce qui ce
dont il devrait être question
aujourd'hui c'est précisément d'élargir
ce que nous considérons en effet être
des régimes pionniers par exemple à ce
salarié de la RATP dont il est question
ces jours-ci qui a été exposée à de
l'amiante dans son travail d'électricien
de l'élargir à ce qu'on appelle les
nomades du nucléaire qui travaillent
dans des entreprises sous-traitantes et
qui sont victimes de pression voilà qui
serait une réforme de justice plutôt que
de pointer ce que vous considérez être
des boucs émissaires sans y parvenir
parce que le la mobilisation est entre
unie de l'ensemble des salariés vous ne
parviendrez pas à aller diviser
il est à 9h58 nous sommes en direct sur
l'antenne de public Sénas si vous nous
rejoignez nous allons retrouver Mathias
sarez en direct de l'hémicycle Mathias
on peut le dire on vient de commencer à
attaquer vraiment l'examen d'un des
points essentiels de la réforme des
retraites oui c'est l'un des points
essentiels on rentre dans le dur si on
peut dire on a ouvert la première partie
le volet des recettes qui comprend donc
6 articles et ce premier article à
savoir celui sur les régimes spéciaux
cet article premier pour rappel c'est
l'article qui vise à les supprimer 5 au
total notamment ceux de la RATP ils
viennent d'être évoqué des salariés des
industries du gaz et de l'électricité ou
encore ceux des clercs de notaire et des
salariés de la Banque de France un débat
qui trouve déjà de l'écho dans
l'actualité puisqu'il y a les syndicats
des électriciens et des gaziers ont
entamé une grève reconductible pour
coller au calendrier de l'examen de cet
article au Sénat et cet article est bien
il est particulièrement il tient
particulièrement à cœur à la droite
sénatoriale qui veut accélérer ses
suppressions en allant même plus loin
que ce que propose le gouvernement
puisque les LR du Palais du Luxembourg
souhaitent supprimer la clause du
grand-père ce qui n'est pas forcément le
cas des centristes ici alors Mathias
dans l'examen de certains articles le 1
que dire de la stratégie de la gauche
sénatoriale et bien on voit que la
gauche sénatoriale continue sur la même
stratégie qui est nous n'avons pas
encore entamé le premier amendement de
cet article 1 un premier abonnement sur
356 il faut le rappeler que déjà des
demandes de prise de parole s'enchaînent
il y en aurait une trentaine la rappeler
le président Carotti a raison de deux
minutes par prise de parole et bien la
première heure ici devrait déjà être
bouclée le président Carotti car rappelé
qu'il souhaitait que ses prises de
parole ne dépassent pas les deux minutes
merci Mathias pour tous ces explications
on retourne donc dans l'hémicycle pour
écouter cette heure de prise de parole
introductive avant le début de l'examen
des amendements et vous l'avez dit il y
en a ensuite 350 énormément de
suppression de cet article là
conquise par les branches les prendre en
compte participent de l'attractivité des
professions à l'heure d'une crise
inédite d'attractivité le gouvernement
mobilise le principe de justice afin de
justifier leur fermeture votre chemin
pour la justice et le nivellement par le
bas et la diffusion dans tous les
secteurs de la crise du travail et de
l'attractivité non la justice c'est
d'ouvrir dans chaque branche la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité en
créant dans chacune les catégories
actives pour les métiers pénibles oui ce
sont des régimes dit pionniers pionniers
parce qu'ils ont existé avant 45 et
pionniers en tant qu'ils adoptent une
méthode de reconnaissance différenciée
des pénibilités par métier afin d'en
prévenir les effets sur la santé et
l'espérance de vie qui devrait être la
méthode dans toutes les branches
vous incitez une partie des salariés ne
bénéficiant pas de la même protection à
demander l'abaissement de la protection
des mieux protégés manœuvre éternelle de
la droite de division pour faire mieux
faire diversion sur les recules que tous
par contre ont quand au régime autonome
ce sont des régimes qui surcottisent
pour des prestations plus généreuses que
les autres régimes sans subvention
publique d'équilibre alors que leur
reproche-t-on de s'exclure de la
solidarité inter régime en partie c'est
peut-être vrai mais cela ne vous
rappelle pas un autre régime autonome de
même fonctionnement
merci je ne vois pas Madame Boyer je ne
vois pas monsieur Durin donc la parole
est à Monsieur broyé
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre selon l'exposé des
motifs l'existence de ces régimes
spéciaux de retraite n'apparaît plus
justifié au regard des principes
d'équité et d'universalité au cœur de
notre modèle social je lisais récemment
dans une excellente revue Alter Eco que
les régimes spéciaux représentent moins
de 3,5% de l'ensemble des cotisants de
France et ne pèse pas tous le même poids
les danseurs de l'Opéra de Paris ne
comptent que 168 personnes et si j'ai
bien compris vous n'allez pas leur
imposer de danser jusqu'à 64 ans quand
les salariés de la Banque de France sont
8400 et partent déjà en moyenne après de
62 ans et ils ont d'ailleurs un régime
je suis pas un grand spécialiste mais
qui me semble qu'il paraît ressemblait
beaucoup aux autres chers collègues et
je me demande si ce n'est pas une espèce
de tentative de commencer par le régime
de la Banque de France pour ensuite
s'attaquer aux autres
de plus ni le régime spécial des i.e.g
158 entreprises de production de
distribution d'électricité ni la RATP
qui peine à recruter nommait en péril
l'ensemble du régime Bruno Le Maire l'a
d'ailleurs déclaré c'est moins un
problème financier qu'un problème
d'équité l'équité c'est une vertu qui
consiste à régler sa conduite sur le
sentiment naturel du juste chers
collègues il n'est pas juste de niveler
par le bas et je voudrais savoir ce que
dit la note de synthèse du
Conseil d'État sur ce sujet
car il ne s'agit pas d'un problème
financier donc monsieur le ministre si
vous ne voulez pas la diffuser
pouvez-vous au moins me dire ce que dit
la note de synthèse sur ce sujet
particulier merci Monsieur Lecomte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre vous gouvernement ont de la
suite dans les idées en 2017 par
ordonnance vous avez supprimé différents
critères de pénibilité du régime général
aujourd'hui maintenant vous nous
proposez de supprimer des régimes
spéciaux qui par branchent tiennent
compte de cette pénibilité vous nous
proposez l'alignement par le bas les
régimes spéciaux qui prennent en compte
branches par branche la pénibilité d'un
certain nombre de métiers des régimes
spéciaux ou souvent les cotisations
salariées sont supérieures à celles du
régime général je pense en particulier
au régime des industriels électriques et
gazières qui est en excédent de 120
millions d'euros je pense aussi alors
que vous allez dans quelques semaines
nous proposer des dispositions par
rapport à des métiers en tension comment
pouvez-vous d'un côté nous dire qu'il y
a des métiers en tension et que
justement une partie de ces métiers en
tension sont des métiers qui sont pris
en compte par ces régimes c'est ces
régimes spéciaux et pourquoi
refusez-vous de maintenir les
protections et la prise en compte
d'alpénibilité de syndrome de ces
métiers enfin et ça déjà été dit en
particulier compte tenu de nos enjeux
énergétiques nous avons besoin dans ces
métiers dans ces métiers d'élargir cette
protection à l'ensemble de ceux qui vont
travailler à la reconstruction d'un
réseau efficace à la mise en oeuvre à la
mise aux normes de nos centrales
nucléaires pourquoi est-ce que vous
voulez fermer ce système ce régime à un
moment ou au contraire nous avons besoin
d'attirer des compétences sur ces
créneaux qui sont des créneaux qui sont
en tension je ne peux pas accepter
finalement que des personnes qui auront
fait des des carrières longues des
carrières pénibles soit alignés sur
celles qui auront eu des carrières plus
confortables il est important il est
important de prendre en compte cette
pénibilité d'avoir toujours en tête que
l'espérance de vie à la retraite elle
dépend aussi de la pénibilité de la
carrière que vous avez eue et cette
prise en compte elle était dans ses
régimes et je ne peux pas me résoudre à
ce que merci
Monsieur Leconte la parole monsieur le
compte respecter le temps de parole
madame Ferret
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre sur cet article deux points à
évoquer tout d'abord je considère que
c'est un véritable détournement de
procédure une fois de plus en proposant
la suppression de ces régimes spéciaux
car dans cet article en tout cas il est
indiqué que cette suppression
n'interviendrait que pour les seules
personnelles recrutés à côté du premier
septembre 2023 sans effet direct sur les
dépenses puisque les premières pensions
versées à ce titre ne seront pas avant
de très nombreuses années donc quel
rapport avec un PLFSS rectifié ou
normalement on doit parler de dépenses
immédiate au titre de l'année 2023 mais
il est vrai aussi que en regardant
l'intégralité des amendements proposés
puis de suivre un peu l'actualité je
crois je me suis même certaine qu'il y
aura après l'article 7 un peu loin un
amendement proposé par notre collègue
Retailleau pour revenir sur ce délai
alors voilà pourquoi pas maintenant
c'est une vraie question détournement de
procédure et puis
la création de ces régimes spéciaux
merci la parole est maintenant à
monsieur Lurel
merci
nous allons donc proposer la suppression
de cinq régimes spéciaux les Français
nous regardent croyez-vous que nous
allons garder notre crédibilité et
croyez moi je fais pas dans la
provocation que nous supprimons au
régime tout à fait spécial très spécial
qui est celui du Sénat qui est un régime
autonome mais pour les Français
spéciales autonomes tout ça c'est la
même chose comment allez-vous garder une
crédibilité pour dire vous êtes des
privilégiés vous êtes des profiteurs
vous n'avez pas de nos critères de
pénibilité d'ailleurs que l'on ne
réintégrer pas les 4 et notamment
l'exposition au pesticides les
vibrations et que sais-je encore et bien
que nous notre travail est hyper pénible
parce que nous travaillons la nuit parce
que nous avons un travail vraiment
pénible et que il nous faut un régime
autonome et très spécial comment
voulez-vous que les Français nous
croient et de dire que en faisant jouer
sur un sentiment qui sont en fait ceux
des bases instincts l'envie la jalousie
sociale ce sont des profiteurs on a
parlé d'ieg et je reprends ce que Noël
les maladi comment voulez-vous faire
croire que les éclairs et autres
salariés d'une notariat qui dont le
salaire est calculé comme pour les
fonctionnaires les sur dernier mois qui
sont excédentaires et qui et qui sont en
pénurie comment allez-vous leur proposer
une telle pauvreté parce qu'ils vont
beaucoup perdre et tous les autres vont
beaucoup perdre on n'est pas accrédible
excellent et je tisse
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est
article premier prouve dès le début
d'examen de ce texte la volonté du
gouvernement de détricoter notre modèle
social en s'attaquant à des régimes
spéciaux présentés comme des sur
privilèges auxquels il faudrait mettre
fin dans les meilleurs délais face à
cela il est nécessaire une nouvelle fois
de rappeler quelques faits premièrement
les régimes spéciaux représentent moins
de 3 et demi pour cent de l'ensemble des
cotisants en France et votre stratégie
d'accabler une minorité pour recevoir
l'assentiment de l'opinion publique ne
semble heureusement pas fonctionner
deuxièmement les régimes spéciaux ne
sont pas une exception française loin de
là monsieur le ministre vous qui aimez
sans cesse comparer notre régime par
rapport au système de nos voisins
européens que pensez-vous des 22% des
retraités issus du régime spéciaux
Pologne ou encore des nombreux régimes
spéciaux existants en Espagne en
Belgique ou en Allemagne alors que nous
devrions porter collectivement un projet
d'amélioration notre modèle social qui
prennent en compte le quotidien des
individus et la pénibilité de chaque
profession vous faites le choix de vous
attaquer à des régimes qui étaient
précurseurs par une juste appréhension
du travail et ses effets sur les
travailleurs
comme cela a été dit déjà de nombreuses
reprises il ne faut pas oublier que lors
de la création du régime général en 45
en 1945 les régimes existants notamment
celui des cheminots ont été maintenus
car ils appelaient comme un horizon à
atteindre pour le régime général nous
reviendrons longuement sur la question
de la pénibilité de nos débats mais je
pense que l'adoption de cette activité
le premier représenterait déjà une
première atteinte particulièrement
regrettable et illustrerait le manque de
considération envers ses professions
pénible au quotidien pour éviter de
nombreux pas en arrière et une atteinte
au fondement même de notre modèle social
mes chers collègues supprimer cet
article premier merci Monsieur le
testeur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues quatre
principes premier principe principe du
dialogue social
chacun voit qu'il est mis à mal puisque
l'unanimité des organisations syndicales
s'opposent à ce texte
deuxièmement le principe du respect des
engagements pris
il est complètement bafoué par les
mesures que vous nous proposez
troisièmement la transparence je vais
revenir là-dessus car cette fameuse note
du Conseil d'État mes chers collègues
qui revient comme un serpent de mer dans
ce débat il faut quand même être clair
monsieur le ministre c'est quand même
pas un document qui est tellement secret
qu'il serait comparable je ne sais pas
au secret de la bombe atomique quelque
chose d'épouvantable qu'on ne peut pas
lire qu'on ne peut pas mettre entre
toutes les mains enfin c'est une
conception complètement infantilisante
s'il conseille d'État fait un travail il
a fait un travail au service de la
République et les parlementaires de la
République doivent bien pouvoir en
prendre connaissance c'est vraiment
ridicule et monsieur le ministre je
voudrais que vous en finissiez avec ces
argusies on doit pouvoir aller je ne
sais pas quel numéro demander frapper à
la porte pour solliciter quelque chose
qui finalement
permettrait d'éclairer le débat et
d’éviter d'ailleurs de faux procès s'il
y en a enfin dernier principe mes chers
collègues nous sommes dans un système
où finalement et je ne vais pas revenir
sur l'éclairs de nos terres défendus
avec talent par Marine ouellinman et
notre
amiurel et l'autre mais c'est un exemple
frappant du fait que au lieu d'être
pragmatique vous avez choisi une vision
dogmatique et nous nous plaidons pour le
pragmatisme par rapport aux situations
spécifiques à la pénibilité et au régime
qui sont parfaitement équilibrées
merci monsieur le Président les salariés
attendent de nous chacune de nous
d'ailleurs que nous puissions défendre
les défendre défendre la population
défendre les emplois leur santé leur
qualité de vie au travail vous avez
supprimé les CHSCT vous voulez faire
disparaître certains régimes mais
surtout vous voulez faire disparaître
les travailleurs eux-mêmes aux Antilles
territoire avocats
les agriculteurs et leurs proches sont
victimes de pesticides et
particulièrement du chlordécone il
souffre d'un cancer vous avez en plus
réintroduit les nicosinoïdes il faut le
savoir et en même temps par
l'incohérence au parc provocation vous
voulez supprimer
ces critères de pénibilité c'est juste
c'est injuste
c'est malheureux c'est méprisant c'est
triste parce que nous sommes ici pour
défendre la population en qualité de
chambre des territoires et je vois que
nous sommes dans une toute autre
dynamique nous voulons détruire tout ce
qui fonctionne détruire l'humain
inhumaniser la politique et c'est
vraiment dommage merci madame la
Présidente
merci monsieur le président ce qui est
intéressant avec le débat sur cet
article enfin quand je dis débat je
m'avance un peu mais au moins avec ce
que nous évoquons est-ce que nous
devinons c'est qu'en fait il nous ramène
à nos conceptions respectives de la
justice et de l'injustice et j'observe
que pour ceux qui soutiennent cet
article 1 qui voit même voir même
veulent l'aggraver en fait quand il
s'agit des salariés l'injustice c'est
toujours ce qu'on plus mais jamais vous
vous dites que ce qu'on moi c'est
injuste jamais vous prenez comme étalons
ceux qui ont davantage de d'acquis
sociaux ceux qui ont mieux de négocié
leur rémunération du travail ceux qui
ont construit par les luttes sociales
des conditions de salariat qui sont
meilleures et ce que j'observe aussi
c'est que ça ne marche que dans un sens
ça ne marche que quand on parle des
revenus du travail parce que quand il
s'agit d'évoquer l'injustice entre les
revenus du travail et les revenus du
capital alors là l'injustice devient
subitement vertueuse que les revenus du
capital assurent des conditions de vie
une qualité de vie bien meilleur que les
revenus du travail ça vous trouble pas
au contraire vous pensez même que plus
c'est injuste plus ça va
contribuer au bonheur économique la
fameuse théorie du ruissellement est
fondée sur la justice or la justice le
ruissellement c'est de l'injustice qui
ruisselle et qui fait encore davantage
d'injustice enfin un mot souvent on
parle du désamour des salariés pour leur
entreprise du manque d'esprit
d'entreprise on appelle ça maintenant
l'esprit corporate dites-vous bien que
ce qu'ils aient l'esprit d'entreprise
c'est cette somme davantage ça allait
des permis de train d'un régime de
retraite d'une réduction sur l'achat des
voitures dans les gens qui travaillaient
dans l'industrie automobile et c'est ça
qui faisait l'esprit d'entreprise c'est
ça qui fait une communauté de travail je
suis pas une nostalgie du capitalisme
social ou du paternalisme social mais
j'en imagine quand même aujourd'hui à la
fois les vertus et la désagrégation de
de vouloir tout niveler par le bas
monsieur Marie
merci monsieur le président
sur les ministres chers collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale vous souhaitez
supprimer ces régimes spéciaux cette
suppression relève d'une logique celle
du président de la République qui je le
cite n'adorent pas ce mot de pénibilité
parce que ça donne le sentiment que le
travail serait pénible c'est ce qui a
amené son gouvernement à l'idée de sa
substance le compte professionnel de
prévention créé en 2015 en supprimant en
2017 les quatre critères principaux qui
permettaient aux salariés qui effectuent
les travaux pénibles de cumuler des
points pour partir à la retraite de
manière anticipée c'est la même logique
qui prévaut avec cet article sur les
régimes spéciaux vous choisissez un
événement par le bas alors que la
justice et l'équité voudraient non
seulement qu'on les conserve mais
surtout que l'on s'en inspire pour
prendre en compte les difficultés de
nombreux métiers car oui messieurs les
ministres Messieurs chers collègues
porter des charges lourdes travailler en
horaire décalé subir des vibrations
mécaniques travailler dans un
environnement chimique dangereux
soulevez les malades tout cela est
effectivement pénible ces régimes sont
le fruit de conquête sociale des
travailleurs concernés de leurs
organisations syndicales c'est le fruit
d'un compromis social notre conception
de la relation au travail diffère de la
vôtre nous considérons que la pénibilité
existe qu'elle pèse sur la santé des
salariés et qu'elle doit se traduire par
des gains d'espérance de retraite en
bonne santé et donc de départ anticipé
c'est là de votre part une mesure de
diversion s'appuyant sur un postulat
faux qui considérait que l'opinion
publique serait favorable à la
suppression de ces régimes spéciaux
c'est une mesure de diversion et de
division des salariés en laissant croire
que ce bénéficiant de ces conditions
serait des privilégiés alors qu'en fait
comme tous les autres il subiront
néfastement votre réforme merci Monsieur
Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre finalement cet article 1 il est
inséparable de l'article 7 vous voulez
tout simplement appliquer au régime
spéciaux les mêmes dispositions et les
intégrer au régime général au sein d'une
réforme profondément injuste et brutale
comme vous faites une réforme de
retraite injuste qui frappe durement
l'ensemble des Français vous avez voulu
détourner leur attention en cherchant
des boucs émissaires fidèle à vos
penchants sarkozytes c'est sur ce qu'on
appelle les régimes spéciaux que vous
avez choisi de vous acharner
vous allez nous chanter la ritournelle
habituelle et faire passer des règles
dérogatoires pour des privilèges vous
allez essayer de diviser les salariés de
ce pays et plus généralement l'ensemble
des Français vous allez nous parler du
chauffeur de bus de la rftp et nous
demander comment se fait-il qu'il ait
des droits particuliers à Paris alors
qu'à Poitiers les chauffeurs de bus n'en
ont pas mais précisément pourquoi n'en
ont-ils pas qu'attendez-vous pour leur
offrir la retraite descente à un âge
décent qu'il mérite à Poitiers comme à
Paris où les horaires et les conditions
de travail sont particulièrement
difficiles pour les chauffeurs et les
chauffeuses de boost au lieu de chercher
à niveler par le bas soyez à la hauteur
de l'histoire de notre pays et
harmoniser par le haut c'est ça la
justice car en vérité ce pdfss
rectificatif est un exercice d'équilibre
budgétaire après avoir rempli rempli les
poches des riches avec la suppression de
l'IS F la suppression de l'exit tax
l'introduction de la flat tax etc il y
en a tellement on peut même plus les
citer c'est aux salariés et aux ouvriers
que vous voulez le faire payer
aujourd'hui et ça c'est profondément
scandaleux
ok merci Madame le héros
merci monsieur le Président alors chers
collègues nous sommes à l'article 1 la
première mesure de votre projet de
réforme c'est la suppression de cinq
régimes spéciaux qui ont été créés pour
mieux compenser la pénibilité des
métiers qui sont exercés les régimes
spéciaux ne sont pas des privilèges mais
la juste compensation des contraintes du
travail travail de nuit travail de
week-end travaillons sous-sol horaires
décalés exposition à des risques
chimiques mais nous connaissons votre
avis sur ces critères de pénibilité la
première mesure du président de la
République en 2017 a été de supprimer
quatre critères de pénibilité la
manutention manuelle des charges les
postures pénibles les vibrations
mécaniques l'exposition risque chimique
c'est une entrée en matière de mépris
pour ceux qui travaillent dans des
conditions particulièrement difficiles
de plus vous choisissez de supprimer
certains régimes la RATP n'est pas celui
des avocats
celui des industries électriques et
gazières mais pas celui des médecins pas
celui des marins non fort justement
alors pourquoi sur quels critères tous
ces régimes sont justifiés expliquer
nous
nous pensons que ces régimes spéciaux
font partie des éléments d'attractivité
justifiés dans ces métiers
4000 ça a été dit tout à l'heure postes
vacant à l'arrière RATP ce sont des
métiers et des et qui ont besoin de
critères particuliers pour recruter pour
compenser la pénibilité que vous avez
rejeté en 2017 contrairement à ce que
vous laissez penser ces régimes spéciaux
ne concernent pas tous les salariés mais
uniquement ceux qui sont soumis à des
travaux difficiles vous supprimez des
acquis sociaux pour les travailleuses et
les travailleurs français ceux qui ne
vivent pas de leur travail et et vous
protégez encore une fois les plus riches
ceux qui ne vivent pas de leur travail
mais qui se contentent de
recueillir d'accueillir et de cueillir
tout simplement le fruit du capital et
de leur
oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président effectivement du coup les
régimes spéciaux c'est vrai que ces
régimes spéciaux qui reviennent à chaque
réforme comme le mal absolu et je note
d'ailleurs et ça vient d'être rappelé
que l'on choisisse ces régimes spéciaux
alors pourquoi pourquoi cet acharnement
pourquoi vouloir revenir sur ses acquis
sociaux
je pense que c'est tout simplement tout
simplement pour diviser je ne vois que
cette raison cliver opposé mépriser les
travailleurs opposer l'agent EDF au
contrat actuel opposer le conducteur de
car Macron au conducteur de RATP alors
que le problème ce n'est pas le statut
du conducteur de RATP ma collègue l'a
rappelé c'est bien le chauffeur Macron
qui n'en bénéficie pas divisé divisé
pour éviter de parler des vraies
inégalités des vrais privilèges les
profits records les véritables
profiteurs les véritables profiteurs de
crise pour éviter de parler de justice
sociale et d'équité parce que vous
n'aimez pas ça et puis cet article 1 est
caractéristique de votre méthode
quelques petits accords avec vos alliés
de droite absence d'études et d'analyses
on attend toujours d'ailleurs
nivellement par le bas du bricolage tout
simplement du bricolage à l'image de ce
texte
merci Monsieur ficher oui merci monsieur
le Président
le président Macron a supprimé des
critères de pénibilité en expliquant
qu'il ne fallait pas donner le sentiment
que le travail était pénible
en visitant le marché de Rungis le
président a peut-être je dis bien
peut-être entendu que les horaires les
charges le stress les troubles
musculo-squelettiques la charge mentale
sont autant de raisons qui rendent les
métiers pénibles difficiles et peu
attractif en visitant le salon de
l'agriculture le président de la
République nous a expliqué que le monde
agricole était un monde qui travaillait
beaucoup sur des métiers pénibles et que
il n'avait pas de week-end il y a pas de
jours fériés et qu'il était important
que il regarde un petit peu leur
situation au travail et il a expliqué
que contenu des difficultés du monde
agricole ça justifiait la retraite à 64
ans pour tous moi je pense que au moment
où s'interroge sur les régimes spéciaux
peut-être qu'il se faut se poser la
question de créer des nouveaux régimes
spéciaux pour tous ces gens qui
travaillent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles je pense au
salarié de registre et je pense aussi au
monde agricole et faire en sorte que ces
métiers souvent
de moins en moins attractifs ne
deviennent à nouveau parce que les
conditions d'exercice mais aussi
l'espérance d'une retraite
agréable est à l'horizon de leur vie
professionnelle je vous remercie c'est
Monsieur Montauger
et merci monsieur le Président chers
collègue monsieur le ministre par cet
article vous comptez mettre fin à la
plupart des régimes spéciaux que notre
système de retraite permet actuellement
il constitue selon vous ne dépense
exagérée qui ne seraient plus
soutenables par notre système de
retraite en réalité et vous le savez les
dépenses liées au régime spéciaux
demeure contenu à proportion des
recettes totales de côtes des
cotisations sociales et plus encore ces
régimes permettent à des secteurs et des
cadres d'emploi de rester attractif là
où le main d'oeuvre essentiel peine à
être trouvé nous avons bien noté que par
ailleurs vous préservez la faculté de
par exemple pour les hauts
fonctionnaires de cotiser et donc de
bonifier leur futur retraite sans
exercer la mission de service public en
rapport avec cette retraite future ce
n'est pas un regret de ma part bien au
contraire mais vous demeurez dur avec
les faibles et faibles avec les forts
nous avons avec cet article premier la
preuve une fois de plus que votre grande
œuvre depuis 2017 est bien casser tous
les statuts un tant soit peu protecteur
le quoi qu'il en coûte socialement comme
viatique politique voilà votre seul
boussole politique ce n'est pas comme
cela qu'on va donner au travail en
France la place et la valeur qui doit
être la sienne et qu'appelle de leur vœu
toutes les composantes de la société
française plus encore monsieur le
ministre au-delà des Français concernés
par les régimes spéciaux les Français ne
veulent pas de votre réforme écoutez-les
merci Madame Préville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues supprimer certains régimes
spéciaux au début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi celle-ci fond rouge agité
que pensez-vous faire diviser les
Français les monter les uns contre les
autres et puis pourquoi certains et pas
d'autres quels sont les justifications
et d'ailleurs pourquoi les supprimer les
régimes spéciaux c'est une longue
histoire sociale de conquête de haute
luttes car rien n'a jamais été donné il
faut le rappeler c'est tout simplement
la prise en compte de la dureté du
travail qu'on appelle maintenant
pénibilité oui certains métiers sont
durs abîmes finalement avons-nous
abandonné l'idée même de progrès social
oui j'ai bien dit progrès ce n'est pas
un gros mot le progrès c'est un avenir
qui donne envie c'est tout d'ailleurs
l'archaïsme de ce débat que nous avons
déconnecté de la transformation en cours
transformation de notre société profonde
qui est l'inspiration
à tous de bien vivre et mieux vivre son
travail
car vu toute la richesse produit dans
notre pays d'autres financements sont
largement possible voilà le vrai défi
que cette loi devrait mettre en œuvre
merci
merci Monsieur dossu Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur ministre mes chers
29 à l'antenne de public Sénas si vous
nous rejoignez depuis 9h45 nous avons
commencé l'examen de l'article 1 de la
réforme des retraites Mathias sarez vous
êtes toujours dans l'émission qu'est-ce
qui se joue depuis 9h45 on voit une
succession de prise de parole de
sénateurs de gauche et bien il y a une
sénateurs de gauche vous l'avez dit ici
on essaye un petit peu de jouer l'usure
Quentin sans négliger le fond pour
autant comme l'a expliqué la socialiste
Annie Le wérou c'est régime spéciaux ce
ne sont pas des privilèges mais des
compensations de la pénibilité l'idée
étant de poser les jalons un petit peu
les enjeux également de cet article
premier on a également vu un peu de
stratégie aussi dans ces prises de
parole du gain de temps parfois aussi on
a entendu parler par exemple de
chlordécone ou de cette fameuse synthèse
du Conseil d'État tant désiré par l'aile
gauche de l'hémicyclicie c'est juste
pour rappeler à nos téléspectateurs cet
article 1 il est important dans la
réforme n'est ce pas il est extrêmement
important particulièrement ici c'est
l'article qui ouvre le volet des
recettes cet article 1 c'est l'article
qui vise à supprimer les régimes
spéciaux 5 au total on l'a assez répété
celui de la RATP des salariés des
industries du gaz de l'électricité ou
encore des clercs de notaire un débat
qui a déjà trouvé de l'écho dans
l'actualité puisque hier les syndicats
des électriciens et des gaziers ont
entamé une grève reconductible et
surtout cet article il va être
particulièrement débattu ici au Sénat on
le sait la droite souhaite aller plus
loin que ce que veut le gouvernement ils
aimeraient supprimer cette clause du
grand-père et là et bien il y a des
petits points de friction avec leurs
alliés du centre bien merci Mathias on
verra tout cela effectivement dans les
prochaines heures mais donc pour
l'instant on est toujours au milieu
d'une trentaine effectivement de prise
de parole introductive sur cet article 1
avant même le début et de l'examen du
plus de centaines de 300 amendements de
suppression de cet article 1 c'est le
sénateur socialiste Olivier Jacquin qui
s'exprime on écoute et donc j'ai envie
de vous parler de ce résume spécial de
la RATP avec ses horaires atypiques la
fréquence des astreintes l'usure
physique pour les uns liés au
souterrains et pour ceux qui sont en
surface à l'air libre
le couscumier au contact difficile des
usagers dans un contexte d'ouverture à
la concurrence de crise du recrutement
le mal-être des conducteurs et
conséquent il y a plus de 4000 offres de
conducteurs non pourvu en Île-de-France
donc c'est des régulations que vous
proposez la suppression du régime
spécial de la RATP ne va certainement
pas faciliter les choses bien au
contraire elle va la
contribuer à rendre encore plus injuste
cette profession c'est absolument
inacceptable c'est pour cette raison que
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article merci Monsieur Houlgate
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les
systèmes de retraite est un ensemble
complexe qui génère de multiples
interactions dès lors que l'on modifie
l'un des éléments celui-ci interagit
avec d'autres générant des effets
induits qu'il est important de discerner
c'est pourquoi le cadre du plfsr est
trop étriqué pour traiter l'ensemble du
sujet la preuve et on la NA discuté hier
c'était l'irrecevabilité de nombreux
amendements et les demandes de nombreux
rapports dès lors que l'on est hors
cadre de financement du cadre de la
sécurité sociale nous abordons l'article
qui supprime certains régimes spéciaux
sous un angle budgétaire sans se soucier
d'une vision globale sur ces régimes et
des conséquences qui découleront de leur
suppression ces régimes spéciaux et cela
a été dit par de nombreux orateurs sont
le fruit d'une histoire l'aboutissement
de longues négociations la prise en
compte d'une spécificité
liée aussi à l'intérêt national ces
régimes spéciaux sont souvent
discrédités et jetés en pâture à
l'opinion sans tenir compte de
l'ensemble des conditions dans lequel
s'exerce les conditions les professions
concernées des contraintes particulières
certes mais aussi de l'ambition en 1945
il fallait reconstruire relever les
défis et mobiliser l'ensemble des
acteurs et des citoyens en 2023 nous
avons l'immense défi de la transition
énergétique du développement des
transports collectifs énergie et
mobilité voici les enjeux pour lequel il
faut désormais une ambition politique et
cette ambition ne pourra jamais être
atteinte en stigmatisant ceux qui
doivent en être les acteurs merci
Madame la rapporteur général c'est à
vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues oui avant
d'attaquer la longue liste des
amendements qui viendront par la suite
je voulais intervenir pour vous dire
quelques mots sur l'expression déjà que
vous avez pu avoir sur les régimes
spéciaux déjà la première chose c'est
que ce n'est pas une suppression c'est
une fermeture du régime de retraite et
que les autres risques de sécurité
sociale restent dans ces régimes
spéciaux mais attention vous qui êtes
toujours férus de sémantique soyez
prudent ce n'est pas une suppression
c'est une fermeture et d'une d'un risque
le deuxième point c'est que vous avez
beaucoup fait appel à l'histoire et moi
je respecte l'histoire et je respecte ce
qui se sont battus pour ces régimes
spéciaux il faut effectivement partie de
l'histoire mais l'histoire on avance
aujourd'hui
dans notre vie contemporaine les choses
ne se passent pas de la même façon et je
pense à ce terme de mutabilité qu'est-ce
que la mutabilité c'est l'adaptation
justement à l'histoire contemporaine
dans l'intérêt général vous parliez de
référendum hier moi je vous propose de
faire un référendum auprès des Français
pour demander s'ils veulent maintenir
les régimes spéciaux et vous verrez et
vous verrez que là le résultat ne sera
pas le même il ne sera pas le même parce
que vous écoutez
générale c'est encore moi qui fait la
police dans cet assemblée on a écouté
tous les intervenants et on écoutera
tous les amendements calmement mais vous
n'interrompez pas les autres orateurs
quand ils sont pas de vos groupes madame
la rapporteur général et elle seule
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
oui alors je voulais rappeler cet aspect
provisoire en fait quand ils ont été
posés ces régimes spéciaux en fait on le
lit dans l'article
l711-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
c'est bien marqué qu'il demeure
provisoirement provisoirement soumise et
donc il n'était pas fait pour durer et
est-ce qu'on vivait après la Libération
comme on vit aujourd'hui non est-ce que
ces métiers sont aussi pénibles
aujourd'hui qu'il était hier non et donc
il faut aujourd'hui quand on parle par
exemple des conducteurs de bus est-ce
qu'on a pas à réfléchir plutôt par
branche plutôt que par statut il me
semble que oui parce qu'être chauffeur
de bus effectivement à la RATP à Paris
c'est pas la même chose que dans une
autre ville moi je pose la question on a
tous ces débat là dans nos familles très
honnêtement les atouts dans nos familles
et tout se pose la question est-ce juste
non est équitable non alors la deuxième
chose sur laquelle je voudrais
intervenir c'est pourquoi nous
supprimons nous souhaitons pardon fermez
ces régimes spéciaux de retraite et bien
parce que aujourd'hui et bien ils sont
déficitaires ils sont déficitaires ils
sont déficients de façon importante on
pourrait regarder tout simplement le
coût par exemple pour la subvention
publique de la SNCF alors la SNCF c'est
différent puisqu'elle est déjà fermée
mais l'état qu'on pense encore
aujourd'hui plus qu'avant encore la RATP
et les IEG et bien c'est 5,7 milliards
d'euros donc c'est quand même les trois
plus importants c'est énorme 5,7
milliards d'euros est-ce juste c'est la
solidarité nationale qui intervient pour
les deux autres pour les autres ce sont
des taxes qu'est-ce qui payent les taxes
c'est l'ensemble des Français c'est
encore la solidarité nationale donc
est-ce normal en fait pour beaucoup
d'entre eux il y a beaucoup moins de
cotisants qu'il y a aujourd'hui de
pensionnés et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle il rentreront dans le régime de
base d'aujourd'hui chers collègues on
aura l'occasion
à travers vos amendements que vous
poserez par ailleurs de revenir sur
chacun de ces régimes spéciales mais
pour terminer je voudrais dire combien
évidemment on est attaché à l'histoire
on est attaché à l'histoire mais il faut
il faut ouvrir les yeux il faut
s'adapter au présent et que fermer ses
régimes spéciaux aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas non plus quelque chose de difficile
en soi
par rapport à tous les autres Français
c'est quand même
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
c'est qu'est-ce que ça représente par
ensemble par rapport à l'ensemble des
Français qui feront des efforts à
travers cette proposition de ce projet
de loi on demande des efforts à tous les
Français quels qu'ils soient
oui merci merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais
simplement rappeler de façon très
factuelle que la majorité sénatoriale
est constante dans ses positions cela
ferait 4 ans qu'on présente
effectivement un projet de réforme qui
prend en compte une convergence des
régimes spéciaux merci Monsieur
ministre de nous avoir rejoint sur cette
philosophie là et vous proposez
effectivement une fermeture une
fermeture aux nouveaux entrants ceux qui
veut dire que ce n'est pas d'une
redoutable brutalité puisque ceux qui
sont dans le régime pourront continuer à
l'être passez leur carrière une
quarantaine d'années ils pourront
bénéficier de passer régime de leur
retraite c'est encore 20 ans et puis ça
veut dire au moins 60 70 ans avant qu'il
y ait la fermeture des régimes donc
c'est pas brutal que les choses soient
bien claires on verra l'article 7 qu'on
pense que on que peut-être accélérer un
petit peu les choses on n'est pas obligé
de faire que c'est dur autant d'années
deuxièmement vous avez décrit des
métiers particulièrement durs pénibles
et vous avez parallèlement parlé de
manque d'attractivité je crois que plus
on met en exerce la brutalité de ces
métiers et moins on trouvera de nouveaux
entrants et je pense que également je
pense que il est important qu'il n'y ait
pas de
différence de traitement au sein de ces
entreprises et nos Français sont
sensibles à ce que le chauffeur de bus
de Paris soumis au même contrainte soit
traitée comme le chauffeur de bus de
d'autres grandes villes pensez-vous
normal quand vous leur direz que les uns
ont leur pension calculer sur les six
derniers mois pendant que les autres
leurs pensions calculer sur les 25
meilleures années cela n'est pas
inégalitaire peut-être que cette
inégalité peut se réduire dans le temps
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il nous semble
et puis nous proposons d'aligner les
métiers et de faire en sorte que l'on
prenne en compte des difficultés dans
d'autres dans d'autres types de statuts
la fonction publique ou le privé quand
vous faites le même métier il faudra
bien qu'un jour on arrive à harmoniser
tout cela et il y a des âges de départ
sur les actifs sur les sédentaires d'une
part qui doivent se rapprocher quand
vous faites le même métier quel que soit
la région vous travaillez sur les actifs
il ne s'agit pas de ne pas prendre en
compte les difficultés il y a les
catégories actives dans les régimes
spéciaux les catégories actives dans le
régime de la fonction publique n'est-il
pas légitime d'aligner ces départs les
super actifs peuvent être également pris
en compte donc vous voyez que cette
réforme est une réforme très progressive
quant à la fermeture de ces régimes
spéciaux et l'on peut effectivement se
poser une question qui a été abordée
pourquoi nous propose-t-on que 5 que 5
régimes pour lequel nous n'aurions pas
nous n'accepterions pas de nouveaux
entrants c'est la question qui se pose
au gouvernement et monsieur le ministre
je pense va nous répondre là-dessus
il a de la chance allez et bien monsieur
le ministre puisque vous êtes sollicité
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames sur
les sénateurs peut-être quelques mots
d'abord pour dire que à la suite de ce
qui vient de dire monsieur le rapporteur
la question que l'on doit se poser
lorsqu'on parle des régimes spéciaux tu
es une question relative à l'équité et
ça ne signifie pas supprimer la prise en
compte de la pénibilité ça signifie
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
salariés voient les conditions
d'exercice de leur activité prise en
compte de la même manière la pénibilité
l'exposition à l'usure mesurée de la
même manière dans une logique
d'effectivité des conditions d'exercice
plutôt qu'une logique de statut puisque
derrière une logique de statut il peut y
avoir des inégalités et derrière un même
statut l'effectivité de l'exposition à
la pénibilité l'effectivité
l'effectivité des conditions de travail
mais évidemment pas la même nous avons
cette volonté nous aurons l'occasion
j'imagine dans quelques heures avec
l'examen de l'article 9 de pouvoir
avancer sur la prise en compte des
critères ergonomiques avancer sur
l'amélioration du des comptes
professionnels de prévention et ainsi
pouvoir faire en sorte que les salariés
et l'ensemble des travailleurs de la des
salariés exposés à des conditions
d'exercice difficiles soit mieux
protégées nous avons fait le choix en
réalité de proposer au Parlement la
fermeture uniquement du régime
d'assurance vieillesse pour 5 régimes
spéciaux et de conserver tout
particulièrement les avantages les
conditions de régime spécifique je pense
à la Comédie Française et à l'Opéra de
Paris mais cela a été évoqué c'est
essentiellement pour des questions d'âge
et d'aptitudes physiques notamment à la
danse et à la produite et à la
représentation physique et puis nous ne
voulons effectivement pas toucher je dis
à Monsieur le kayak qui l'a évoqué nous
ne voulons pas toucher à la question des
régimes spéciales des marins et des
pêcheurs et à travers les marins et les
pêcheurs en réalité nous pensons à tous
ceux qui sont affiliés à Lénine pourquoi
est-ce que nous ne voulons pas toucher à
l'affiliation à l'énigme parce que ce
métier de marin-pêcheur est celui qui
est le plus exposé à des conditions
d'exercices particulièrement difficile
et le chiffre plus dramatique encore
c'est le métier dans lequel la part des
accidents mortels et la plus importante
parce que malheureusement lorsqu'on est
pêcheurs en haute mer et notamment en
eau très froide le moindre accident peut
être absolument tragique et mortel pour
dire les mots tels qu'ils sont et c'est
une des conditions pour lesquelles nous
avons fait le choix de maintenir le
Lénine pour le reste en matière de
régime d'assurance vieillesse c'est une
véritable harmonisation à l'exception
des trois régimes que je viens d'évoquer
il y a monsieur le président
trois remarques que je voulais faire
pour conclure deux sur les régimes
spéciaux et un une pardon sur une
question que j'ose qualifiée de
récurrente dans le débat depuis hier la
première remarque que je veux faire
concerne la question de l'équilibre
économique de l'équilibre financier des
régimes spéciaux en réalité ces régimes
ne sont pas équilibrés pour la plupart
d'entre eux on ne peut pas considérer
qu'un régime est équilibré quand il est
équilibré par le versement d'une
subvention d'État et on ne peut pas plus
considérer qu'un régime est équilibré
lorsqu'il est équilibré par le paiement
d'une contribution par les usagers par
les consommateurs je pense au régime des
IEG puisque la contribution pour
l'acheminement qui porte mal son nom
mais c'est la contribution pour la
cheminement s'élève à 1 milliard 800
millions d'euros et pardon de le dire
comme ça mais il est plus facile
d'équilibrer un régime lorsqu'il
bénéficie d'une contribution fiscale
spécifique à hauteur d'un milliard 8 que
lorsqu'il n'en bénéficie pas et donc
cette notion d'un équilibre des régimes
ne tient pas dès lors que l'on retire
les subventions spécifiques versées par
l'État et certains régimes je pense à la
RATP
des contributions qui ont un caractère
fiscal payé sur la facture de chacun des
consommateurs quand on parle des IEG et
donc nous avons ce devoir de
responsabilité par rapport au coût pour
la collectivité que représente
aujourd'hui des régimes qui parlent
logiques de statut entretien des
iniquités alors même qu'ils sont coûteux
pour l'ensemble des contribuables ce qui
est évidemment n'est pas n'est pas
légitime la vraie question derrière le
financement des régimes spéciaux tient
finalement à une seule alternative
est-ce qu'il revient au contribuable de
financer les avantages ou les
dispositions particulières d'un régime
spécial quand bien même il serait
considéré que ça relève de
l'attractivité des métiers où est-ce
qu'il revient aux entreprises dans
lesquelles resteront des régions
spéciaux pour au titre de l'application
de la clause de grand-père d'assurer
l'attractivité des métiers par le
dialogue le dialogue social et un
financement spécifique quitte à ce que
ce soit un financement passant par
l'usager ou le client selon les cas
plutôt que le contribuable général et
c'est ça la question de l'équité est-ce
que cette contribuable ou est-ce que
c'est dans le cadre du dialogue social
d'assurer l'attractivité d'un métier la
deuxième remarque que je souhaite faire
concerne une solution ou une alternative
qui nous a été proposée à l'occasion des
interventions cette alternative consiste
à dire mais finalement s'il y a une
difficulté ou une forme d'iniquité c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs une façon de la
reconnaître il faudrait que l'ensemble
de celles et ceux qui exercent des
métiers
identiques aux proches puissent
bénéficier de mêmes conditions et j'ai
notamment entendu le fait que les agents
de conduite des métros des bus d'autres
communes que celles couvertes par la
RATP devrait pouvoir bénéficier des
mêmes conditions de départ anticipé et
souvent cette solution nous est proposée
au nom du pragmatisme c'est la
démonstration que le pragmatisme et le
réalisme ne font pas toujours bon ménage
et qu'en tout cas ils ne sont pas
synonymes parce que cela aurait un coût
qui serait absolument inaccessible
impossible à financer sauf à renchérir
de manière drastique le coût des
services rendus par celles et ceux qui
seraient ainsi concernés et c'est
évidemment une envisageable enfin
dernier point mais qui n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec les régimes spéciaux à
plusieurs
à plusieurs reprises dans les
interventions comme hier est revenu la
question de si j'ose dire la fameuse
note de synthèse du Conseil d'État
je répète ce que j'ai dit hier le
Conseil d'État et je fais une offense à
personne de le rappeler devant vous le
Conseil d'État est bicéphale il a un
rôle de juridiction et puis il a un rôle
de conseiller du gouvernement et dans le
cas des conseils du Conseil d'État au
gouvernement un certain nombre de
documents sont publiques un Cerdon de
document le son depuis 2015 par une
décision orale du président François
Hollande et d'autres lorsqu'il concerne
les lois de finances les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale n'ont
pas de caractère public et seul un
certain nombre de parlementaires du fait
de leur compte de leur prérogatives de
contrôle d'évaluation peuvent avoir
accès si le souhait et dans des
conditions déterminées par la loi mais
aussi par le fonctionnement du
secrétariat général du Gouvernement
avoir accès à ces notes et à ses
documents et avoir accès ne signifie pas
être autorisé à les publier je le
souligne au passage et donc si parmi
vous et je ne doute pas que c'est le cas
parce que vous êtes organisé comme
l'Assemblée nationale en la matière si
parmi vous les parlementaires qui
disposent de ces prérogatives souhaitent
consulter ses documents le secrétariat
général du gouvernement pas leur
disposition mais vous pouvez me demander
de rendre public une note qui n'a pas
vocation à l'être autant de fois que
vous le souhaitez c'est votre droit ça
sera aussi mon droit de maintenir cette
réponse et même de considérer qu'elle a
un caractère définitif j'ai juste eu un
peu de surprise à devoir appeler un
ancien président de la commission des
lois les principes de séparation des
pouvoirs et de rôle du Conseil d'État
voilà monsieur le Président ce que je
voulais dire pour répondre aux
intervenants merci Monsieur le Ministre
alors
j'ai d'abord un rappel le règlement je
sais pas si c'est Fabien gay ou le
président Laurent
il y en a deux oh bah alors allons-y
abondance de bien ne nuit pas
qui veut monsieur Fabien gay allez-y
merci monsieur le Président rappelle au
règlement selon l'article 36 de nos
règlements c'est le ministre vous le
savez nos travaux sont extrêmement
suivis d'ailleurs les salariés des
industriels électriques et gazières ont
décidé des hier soir mais leur syndicats
majoritaires la CGT de reprendre leur
outil industriel en main
dans le nucléaire dans l'hydro et dans
le thermique de Flamanville à Tricastin
à Martigues ce matin à Paluel à
saint-alba Ajaccio c'est des ores et
déjà 4000 mégawattheure en moins sur le
réseau électrique dans le même temps les
Robins des bois ont remis d'hier dans un
dizaine des centaines de points
d'électricité à celles et ceux Carman
avait été privé où on basculé aux
artisans commerçants ou petites
collectivités au tarifs zéro et il se
rappelle d'ailleurs que lorsque nous
avons proposé le tarif réglementé pour
toutes les collectivités vous l'avez
refusé comme vous avez refusé aussi de
sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité alors nous nous les
soutenons et saluons leur mobilisation
et nous reposons une question et je
repose directement monsieur le Président
rotaïo puisque nous partageons la
question la souveraineté
électrique
énergétique de la France et que nous
nous apprêtons à voter au mois de juin
juillet la création de 8 nouveaux opère
comment nous allons le faire sans
salariés sous statut et les régimes
spéciaux comment nous allons réattirer
des talents sans attractivité comment
vous allez faire il faut nous le dire ou
alors vous vous satisfaisez du dumping
social et que nous allions chercher des
travailleurs et des travailleurs de
l'autre côté du monde c'est-à-dire que
ce qui aujourd'hui empêchait le père
Flamanville de naître vous vous en
satisfaisez et c'est en réalité
l'organisation du dumping social que
vous voulez il faut répondre à cette
question et vous ne pourrez pas rester
silencieux aujourd'hui je vous remercie
monsieur gay vous le voyez encore des
demandes de prise de parole de la gauche
mais on peut le dire sur le ton en tout
cas elle a séance se déroule de façon
diamétralement opposée à la façon dont
c'était déroulé les débats sur cette
réforme à Assemblée nationale pour en
parler on va rejoindre notre journaliste
Mathias arez vous êtes toujours dans
l'hémicine alors Mathias on a vu un coup
de sang de Roger carochi pour rétablir
l'ordre en séance que s'est-il passé il
y a absolument Quentin il a fallu
attendre la première prise de parole de
la majorité pour animer un petit peu les
débats ici après une vingtaine
d'interventions de la gauche sur
l'intérêt ou non de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux c'est Elisabeth
Doisneau rapporteur du budget de la
Sécurité sociale qui a piqué les
sénateurs écologistes communistes et
socialiste par leur expliquant que si
demain il devait savoir un référendum
sur cette suppression et bien le
résultat leur déplairait vibrontin à
gauche où vous en doutez qui a nécessité
l'intervention vous l'avez dit du
président de séance rejet carouti pour
ramener le calme Roger carotic a rappelé
au sénateur que toutes leurs prises de
parole avait été respecté dans le calme
on retourne dans les musiques parce que
ça continue à s'agiter
rénale non monsieur le Président Laurent
ça suffit monsieur rénal ce que l'on
voit c'est que Roger caroutchi voilà
ça va ça va ça va ce que l'on voit c'est
que Roger caoutchi fait voilà appliquer
le règlement de façon très ferme une
seule une seule demande de rappel de
règlement sur un seul thème c'est la
règle et donc ici il y a deux fois le
même thème et bien il n'est pas autorisé
sur appel au règlement en retournant
dans les bicycle sur la forme je n'ai
pas de commentaire mais sur le fond je
partage l'idée que nous devons dans
cette assemblée nous respecter et nous
écouter donc sur ce fond là pas de
difficulté j'aurais aimé cependant que
votre interpellation qu'on comment dire
soit élargi à l'ensemble des
intervenants et je le dis très
amicalement mais l'intervention de
madame le rapporteur général qui
s'adresse à une partie de l'hémicycle en
lui posant des questions à peine des
réponses car comment ferions-nous si je
rappelle pour ceux qui nous écoutent que
lorsqu'on est intervenu une fois on ne
peut plus réintervenir dans le débat
donc comment pouvons-nous répondre à des
questions qui ne sont posées après le
débat donc je demanderai à ce que
finalement la forme du débat le respect
évidemment de la parole de chacun mais
aussi pas d'interrogations de la part
des rapporteurs merci donc
[Applaudissements]
allez allez vous interpellez pas les uns
les autres ça sert à rien merci
je suis le président
ceci est un rappel au règlement
le 36 du Règlement sur l'organisation de
nos travaux on demande une suspension de
séance de 10 minutes pour réorganiser
les dossiers de séance suite à de
nombreuses
erreurs matérielles dans l'eau dans
l'ordre des signataires des amendements
je vous remercie
l'ordre des signataires qui
n'apparaissent pas merci il y a pas de
suspension de droit mais si c'est pour
corriger des erreurs matériels cinq
minutes ça permettra tout le monde de se
calmer 5 minutes
voilà retour en salle des conférences la
salle qui jouxte les mythique puisque
vous venez de le vivre en direct sur
notre antenne il y a une suspension de
séance de 5 minutes au moment où si on
peut le dire les esprits commencer à
s'échauffer et c'est ce qu'on était en
train d'essayer de commencer à vous
expliquer avec Mathias ares on va le
rejoindre Mathias expliquez-nous Mathias
effectivement il y a eu une remarque de
la rapporteur général qui est une élue
centriste qui a un peu échauffé les
esprits et depuis on voyait que
commencer à avoir une Broca dans
l'hémicycle expliquez-nous ça y est il
commençait à avoir un petit peu de
tension dans cette émission qu'il a
fallu une vingtaine d'interventions de
la gauche avant que la rapporteur du
budget de la Sécurité sociale vous
l'avez dit Elisabeth Doisneau ne
prennent la parole une prise de parole
qui est un petit peu électrisée
l'atmosphère ici puisqu'elle a rappelé
au sénateur écologiste communiste et
socialiste que si demain il devait y
avoir un référendum sur la suppression
des régimes spéciaux et bien le résultat
leur déplairait vivre bronca à gauche
vous en douter qui a nécessité que le
président de séance Roger Carotti
reprennent la main pour calmer les
esprits et rappeler au sénateur et bien
que leur prise de parole avait été
respectées entre temps depuis il y a eu
quelques petits soubresauts jusqu'à
cette demande de suspension de séance de
la part de la gauche pour une question
d'ordre dans les amendements et Mathias
que dire de la façon dont Roger karucci
mène la séance depuis le début de
l'examen à 9h30 bien écoutez il y a eu
d'abord donc cette motion de renvoi
partiel en commission jusque là tout
allait bien pendant les prises de parole
également même si on a senti un petit
peu d'ironie dans la voie de Roger
caoutchou au moment d'expliquer qu'il y
allait avoir plus d'une trentaine
d'orateurs avant l'examen des différents
amendements on va dire que c'est une il
tient plutôt bien sa séance le président
de séance ici rappelant à chaque fois à
chaque sénateur et bien que les prises
de parole ne doivent pas dépasser les
deux minutes et que ce qui doit primer
ici dans l'hémicycle et bien c'est avant
tout le respect et l'écoute au moment
des échanges voilà il y a donc au moment
où je vous parle où nous vous parlons
avec Mathias une suspension de quelques
minutes pourquoi parce que d'après les
sénateurs de gauche il y aurait des
erreurs dans la façon dont sont signés
dans les logiciels ici au Sénat les
amendements alors ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on écoute un extrait et bien de
la prise de parole de Elisabeth Doisneau
Elisabeth Doisneau qui donc siège sur le
banc de la commission puisqu'elle est
rapportée général du budget de la
Sécurité sociale et donc Elisabeth
Doisneau qui a pu comme cela expliquer
aussi sur le fond ce qui se jouait avec
non pas la suppression la fermeture des
régimes spéciaux on écoute ils avaient
Doisneau pourquoi nous supprimons nous
souhaitons pardon fermer ces régimes
spéciaux de retraite et bien parce que
aujourd'hui et bien ils sont ils sont
déficitaires ils sont déficients de
façon importante on pourrait regarder
tout simplement le coût par exemple pour
la subvention publique de la SNCF alors
la SNCF c'est différent puisqu'elle est
déjà fermée mais l'état qu'on pense
encore aujourd'hui plus qu'avant encore
la RATP et les IEG et bien c'est 5,7
milliards d'euros donc c'est quand même
les trois plus important c'est énorme
5,7 milliards d'euros est-ce juste c'est
la solidarité nationale qui intervient
voilà nous sommes en direct il est
presque 11 heures sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat nous suivons depuis 9h35
quel examen de la réforme des retraites
ici à la Chambre haute alors retour sur
un autre événement depuis ce matin avec
vous Mathias on entend la gauche qui se
plaint de ne pas disposer d'un avis ou
d'une note de synthèse on ne voit pas la
différence très très bien du Conseil
d'État expliqué nous de quoi il s'agit
il y a absolument Quentin depuis le
matin et bien il y a plusieurs dans
plusieurs prises de parole des sénateurs
de gauche qui demandent à ce que cette
note de synthèse du Conseil d'État sur
les textes des retraites soit rendus
publics elle a été demandée avec
répétition au ministre Olivier du socle
qui a donc du prendre la parole c'était
il y a à peu près 20 minutes il a
rappelé le ministre que depuis 2015 les
avis du Conseil d'État sont rendus
publics les avis qui se réfèrent à
différentes catégories de textes mais
pas pour les textes qui ont un lien avec
le financement ou le budget on parle là
de notes de synthèse ceci n'ont pas
vocation à être rendu public certains
sénateurs comme députés ont des
prérogatives prérogatives pour y avoir
accès mais ils ne peuvent pas les rendre
public un olivier du soft un peu
ironique qui leur a répondu vous pouvez
le demander autant que vous le voulez je
suis dans mon droit de vous répondre et
bien que vous n'y aurez pas accès
publiquement merci Mathias pour ces
explications ce que je propose c'est
qu'on retourne dans l'hémicycle puisque
la séance vient de reprendre en direct
notre désaccord face à la suppression
des régimes spéciaux à contrario nous
plaidons pour leur généralisation au
régime général oui chers collègues leur
généralisation car il s'agit du régime
pionnier en matière de droit à la
retraite ces dernières reconnaissent
réellement la pénibilité physique du
travail qui raccourcit parfois la durée
de vie la pénibilité ce sont les
contraintes qui a des services qu'il
faut assurer 365 jours par an et 24
heures sur 24 et ce dans des conditions
exigeantes avec le travail de nuit des
horaires décalées des astreintes des
charges lourdes un environnement de
travail bruyant une exposition au CMP en
août les régimes spéciaux permettent une
indexation des pensions sur les salaires
chose que ne permet pas le régime
général qui index les pensions sur les
prix ce dernier type d'indexation fait
perdre chaque année du pouvoir d'achat
chez nos retraités en effet le recul sur
15 ans peut être estimé à 20%. autrement
dit une pension qui ne représentait à la
liquidation 2015 que 80% du SMIC ne va
plus représenter en 2030 60% du SMIC
l'indexation sur les prix fait donc
basculer une grande partie des retraités
dans la pauvreté et dans la dépendance
aux aides sociales c'est pourquoi il est
absolument
urgent d'initier dès maintenant un
retour pour tout et tous à l'indexation
sur les salaires cela constitue une
condition sinequanone à la pérennité du
système par répartition donc nous
demandons la généralisation des régimes
spéciaux régimes général et donc la
suppression de ces amendements et Madame
l'a rapporteur général quand vous donnez
des arguments il faut être sûr de votre
fête parce que nous avons auditionné à
la commission des affaires sociales
Monsieur Nicolas midjaville qui est le
directeur général de la Caisse nationale
des industries électriques et gazières
et il nous a dit qu'il y avait que le
son régime était parfaitement équilibré
et il a même parlé d'une trésorerie de
700 millions qui était gérées par la
cosse donc on veut débattre on n'est pas
d'accord mais au moins avec des
arguments qui reposent sur la réalité
des faits je vous remercie merci Madame
ponce le 129
merci monsieur le Président alors sur
cette suppression
ne sachant pas comment justifier sa
réforme le gouvernement a tenté
d'invoquer avec un certain culot la
justice sociale ainsi dans l'exposé des
motifs vous le savez c'est justifié au
regard des principes d'équité
d'universalité etc bien procéder à une
politique de justice et d'équité nous le
redisons serait justement d'appliquer
des mesures ambitieuses et sérieuses de
prise en compte de la pénibilité à tous
les travailleurs de toutes les branches
accomplissant des travaux pénibles ou
exposés à des facteurs de pénibilité
plutôt que de niveler les droits sociaux
par le bas la bonne question de ces
régimes spéciaux elles sont-ils
justifiées ou pas par la pénibilité des
métiers définis comme catégorie active
dans des tableaux je vous rappelle quand
même très très pertinent très subdivisé
incluant les critères ces critères que
nous essayons en vain de faire
reconnaître pour notamment les départs
anticipés dans les autres branches je
dirais aussi
c'est plus
voilà je le dirai en explication de
votre
président allez-y
donc j'ai entendu dans les entretiens
quelqu'un qui a dit oui mais dans ces
régimes là on part et quelquefois on
n'est pas cassé ah bon tout est dit
qu'on qualifie l'effet d'aubaine et ils
ont dit que c'est un effet d'aubaine le
départ anticipé de salariés exposé à des
risques mais pas cassés voilà donc les
effets d'aubaine ne sont jamais ceux des
employeurs mais on traque sans répit ses
effets d'aubaine de salariés couverts
par leur appartenance à une catégorie
active
ou un régime spécial et qui partent
alors que c'est une honte il pouvait
encore travailler jusqu'au 1er symptômes
de dégradation de leur santé
et monsieur le Président Gontard oui
merci merci le monsieur le Président
cette suppression concerne les régimes
spéciaux des industries électriques et
gazières de la région autonome des
transports parisiens d'éclairer employés
de notaire de la Banque de France et des
membres du Conseil économique social et
environnemental pour les agents qui sont
recrutés à compter du premier septembre
2023 la suppression de ces régimes
spéciaux est une stratégie de plus du
gouvernement pour faire oublier le
principal le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans ce
gouvernement est prêt à toutes les
manœuvres pour opposer les Français les
uns contre les autres les régimes
spéciaux sont stigmatisés pour pouvoir
opérer un nivellement par le bas des
droits à la retraite le but ce
gouvernement est clair fissurer le front
unique qui se dresse contre cette
réforme injuste cette stigmatisation est
d'autant plus injuste que les régies
spéciaux ne concernent pas tous les
salariés de ses professions mais
seulement ceux qui occupent des
fonctions
avec des conditions de travail
difficiles seul 5% par exemple des
salariés de la RATP sont concernés par
le régime spécial certains régimes
spéciaux avaient précédemment été
supprimés mais seulement car le régime
général avait été réformé et que ces
conditions étaient proches de ces 10
régimes
ces régimes protègent les salariés en
prenant en compte la pénibilité de leur
travail sont également nécessaires pour
attirer de nouveaux salariés vers des
secteurs difficiles les difficultés de
recrutement dans certains secteurs nous
vont faire que s'accroître cette volonté
de suppression est encore une fois
totalement seule puisque le but est de
remplacer les régimes spéciaux par le
compte professionnel de prévention c'est
de paix dispositif à la fois Unity et
contre-productif qui est même considéré
par la Cour des comptes comme pas la
hauteur des objectifs qui lui mettaient
assignés et qui n'a plus aucune vertu de
prévention cependant rien d'étonnant ici
puisque cette réforme injuste dans la
continuité de la politique menée par
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 la
pénibilité et la souffrance au travail
qui touchent les salariés sont
complètement
ignorés par ce gouvernement et mais le
Macron avait d'ailleurs dans ce sens
supprimer quatre critères de pénibilité
en 2017 les postios pénibles les
vibrations mécaniques les manusations de
charge lourdes et les achats chimiques
dangereux et voilà que le gouvernement
veut mettre non supprimer ce qu'il reste
de droit aux salariés qui travaillent
dans des conditions difficiles
et le 131 monsieur dessus merci monsieur
le Président mais tout d'abord je vais
commencer par une alerte le président
Retailleau dans sa discussion générale
nous nous mettait en garde du choix à
faire entre la société de paresse et la
société du travail mais je voulais
l'alerter un peu sur la paresse qui
semble avoir gagné les rangs de son
groupe sur la langueur de de non débat
de la droite et puis madame la
rapporteur madame la rapporteur vous
avez demandé à que qu'on fasse faire des
efforts à tous les Français à tous les
Français vraiment
certains de mes collègues l'ont dit il y
a un régime que qui n'est pas étudié
dans ce dans ce projet loi c'est le
nôtre et quel exemple nous donnons aux
Français si nous nous attaquons à des
régimes sans nous attaquer aux nôtres
fort avec les faibles faibles avec
l'effort on connaît la maxime vous
continuez à la dérouler vous êtes dur
avec les travailleuses et les
travailleurs ceux qui bénéficient des
super profits sont exemptés ceux qui
font la rente sont exemptées sauf que ce
sont belles et bien bel et bien ce
celles et ceux qui travaillent qui
savent ce qu'est la valeur du travail
une valeur non pas morale mais
économique et marchande comme la
rappeler notre collègue Laurence
Rossignol ce sont bel et bien c'est
travailleurs du public et du privé qui
font tourner le pays
ce sont eux qui maintiennent le pays à
flot depuis la pandémie oui nous aurions
aimé débattre en préambule des facteurs
de pénibilité avant de niveler tout le
monde vers le bas alors monsieur le
ministre nous aimerions vous suivre dans
dans votre logique qui veut sortir de la
logique de statut pour arriver à la
reconnaissance de facteurs de pénibilité
et d'usure mais c'est l'article premier
qui nous permet pas ça à l'article
premier ce sont c'est un article de
division
et donc pour nous ça sera non comme les
suivants mais si vous voulez qu'on vous
suive si vous voulez qu'on qu'on aborde
les facteurs d'usure et de pénalités
appelés en priorité l'article 9 par
exemple qu'on débattre d'abord de ces
facteurs là avant avant avant de niveler
tout le monde vers le bas je vous
remercie le 2 voilà il est 11h08 sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat les sénateurs
qui t'ont qui ont donc entamé l'examen
de l'article 1 sur la suppression de 5
régimes spéciaux et nous venons tout
juste de commencer l'examen d'une série
d'amendements il y en a plus de 300 des
amendements de suppression de la mesure
dans la réforme en réalité les régimes
spéciaux ne concernent pas l'ensemble
des salariés du secteur mais uniquement
ceux qui ont des conditions de travail
des plus pénibles ainsi en 2019 les
retraités recevant une pension des
régimes spéciaux représentés environ 6%
de l'ensemble des salariés mettre fin au
régime spéciaux sous prétexte d'équité
et de supposer universalité est une
diversion pour faire oublier que tout le
monde va pâtir du report de l'âge légal
dire que les régimes spéciaux sont un
privilège à abolir et faux la situation
devant l'emploi est inégale certaines
professions par leurs horaires leur
impact sur le corps le stress qu'ils
engendent son particulièrement pénibles
ces régimes spéciaux sont la
contrepartie de suggestions
particulières par ailleurs les métiers
concernés sont essentiels à notre pays
est ces secteurs font face à des
difficultés de recrutement la mise en
cause de ces régimes spéciaux de
retraite renforcera cette carence
prendre en compte cette pénibilité n'est
pas un privilège c'est une mesure de
justice sociale mais au-delà et cela a
été dit ce sont des régimes pionniers
souvent
issus de la négociation votre volonté
suppression de ces régimes et bien une
mesure idéologique et dogmatique et donc
plutôt que de chercher à aligner les
droits des salariés vers le bas
en supprimant les régimes spéciaux il
faut au contraire que l'ensemble des
salariés exposés à la pénibilité
puissent partir plus tôt ce serait cela
la justice sociale je vous remercie le
280 monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement il propose comme les autres
de supprimer cet article 1 parce qu'on
ne supprime pas des décennies d'histoire
sociale française comme cela sans aucune
négociation sans aucune compensation et
sans aucun accord avec aucune
organisation syndicale et puis cette
article cette suppression des régimes
spéciaux c'est vraiment l'arbre qui
cache la forêt j'ai bien entendu que le
président Retailleau voulait supprimer
ce qu'il appelle des CAF flagrants
d'injustice lors des cas flagrants
d'injustice à supprimer il y en a
beaucoup et il y en a des vrais
vous avez supprimé l'ISF à un moment où
les inégalités de patrimoine
augmentaient rétablissons-le vous avez
instauré la flat tax qui fait que le
travail est bien plus taxé que le
capital supprimons-la vous avez refusé
d'instaurer le minimum jeunesse à un
moment où les jeunes se représentent un
quart des bénéficiaires des Restaurants
du Coeur et bien instaurons ce minimum
jeunesse vous avez refusé de taxer les
super profits on a appris ce matin que
c'est ma CGM avait réalisé en 2022 23,5
milliards de bénéfices qui sont taxés au
total à
2%. parce qu'il y a une taxe automnage
plutôt qu'un en position sur les
bénéfices et bien supprimons ce
privilège si il s'agit de supprimer des
privilèges il y a des idées s'il s'agit
de supprimer le régime spécial des super
profits ou des traits dans ce pays et
bien commençons par là et vous nous
trouverez à vos côtés en attendant nous
proposons de supprimer cet article et
pourquoi pas comme le proposait la
rapporteur général de faire un
référendum
merci le 312 n'est pas défendu le 342
madame briquet
merci à Monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues messieurs les messieurs les
ministres les régimes dis spéciaux nous
l'avons largement étayé tout à l'heure
un son le résultat de lutte et de
conquête sociale aussi aujourd'hui quel
besoin de fermer les régimes spéciaux en
les présentant qui plus est comme des
régimes de faveur aucun besoin aucune
urgence les dépenses des régimes
spéciaux diminuent de façon constante en
part de PIB et les ressources
nécessaires pour assurer cet équilibre
diminue donc également cette volonté de
suppression des régimes des régimes
spéciaux relèvent plus d'une manœuvre de
diversion pour atténuer la seule réalité
de cette de cette réforme le report de
l'âge légal dont tout le monde pâtira
incontestablement par ailleurs à l'heure
où les secteurs concernés peinent à
recruter la mise en cause de certains
régimes spécifiques de retraite
seraient contre-productif
alors que on voit on voit bien la
nécessité qu'il y a de renforcer
l'attractivité des secteurs déficitaires
en emploi je crois que cette mesure est
pour le moins mal venue
merci le 366 madame Ferré merci monsieur
le Président cet amendement vise à
supprimer l'article premier car vous
monsieur le ministre souhaitez mettre
fin au régime spéciaux sous prétexte
d'équité et de supposer une universalité
mais qui est une véritable diversion
pour faire oublier qu'en fait cette
réforme ces deux ans de plus pour tous
n'oublions pas l'essentiel on va dire où
le l'argument majeur de cette réforme
deux ans de plus pour tous c'est aussi
avec cette article une fois de plus
votre volonté de diviser les Français
divisez les Français entre ceux qui
seraient privilégiés et les autres ce
qui serait privilégié et qui vivent des
conditions de travail extrêmement
pénibles mais il est vrai que ça n'est
pas votre je dirais priorité puisque dès
2017 vous avez supprimé 4 critères de
pénibilité sur 10 alors vous êtes dans
cette logique effectivement de
conception même de la pénibilité que
vous ne voulez même plus ainsi mais
usure professionnelle et je voulais
revenir sur ce que monsieur le
rapporteur Savary a indiqué en précisant
que cette mesure il n'y avait pas de
brutalité dans cette musique car elle se
mettrait en place progressivement et
seulement d'ici 43 ans mais alors
pourquoi Monsieur Retailleau qui est du
même groupe politique a-t-il déposé un
amendement additionnel après l'article 7
et seulement après l'article 7 et
pourquoi pas maintenant qui vise à
mettre en oeuvre cette suppression des
régimes spéciaux dès 2023 si ça ça n'est
pas une mesure brutale alors comment
l'appelle-t-on il est vrai que quand on
lit les signataires la liste des
signataires de cet amendement on y
retrouve pas tout les membres du groupe
les républicains mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est votre affaire et cela vous regarde
et nous nous regarderez pas pour autant
ce que je constate c'est une fois de
plus votre silence votre silence donc ce
débat qui est important pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et pour leur avenir
le 449 monsieur fiché oui merci monsieur
le Président alors où les secteurs
concernés sont pour plusieurs d'entre
eux en manque d'agents et de salariés la
mise en cause des régimes spéciaux de
retraite renforcera cette carence de
recrutement alors j'ai bien compris ce
que nous suggérer tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur Savary qui
viennent ne parlons pas de ces métiers
difficiles afin de ne pas augmenter les
difficultés de recrutement je trouve que
c'est un peu juste comme méthode la fin
des régimes spéciaux c'est une diversion
pour faire mieux passer la pilule du
passage à la retraite à 64 ans en fait
certaines professions par leurs horaires
leur impact sur le corps ou le stress
sont particulièrement pénibles et sont
parfois source de souffrance afin de
réduire le nombre de salariés qui
malheureusement se retrouve en situation
de
longue maladie Suite à de nombreux
interventions de chirurgie pour les
troubles musculo-squelettiques il
vaudrait mieux essayer d'avoir un départ
à la retraite et que tu as pas prolongé
de deux années et donc je propose que
l'on supprime cet article je vous
remercie merci le 484 monsieur Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président on discute
sur les régimes spéciaux mais finalement
ce débat nous permet de constater qu'il
y a vraiment deux visions du modèle
social français qui s'oppose pour vous
non seulement il n'est plus possible de
prélever un euro supplémentaire sur les
grandes entreprises les grandes fortunes
mais en plus il faudrait en permanence
diminuer leur taux de prélèvement par
conséquent afin de maintenir le budget
en équilibre il convenait de baisser
hier les prestations de l'assurance
chômage et aujourd'hui les pensions de
retraite et maintenant de détricoter les
régimes spéciaux qui protègent ceux et
celles qui exercent des métiers pénibles
pour vous la vie et le marché se
confondent l'utilité se mesure à la
seule valeur commerciale avant de vous
demander comment améliorer la vie des
êtres humains et le sort de la planète
qui les nourrit vous commencez toujours
par vous demander à quoi consentiront
les Puissances de l'Argent or à chaque
crise et pour les Puissances de l'Argent
le de réclamer de l'État et quand la
prospérité là elle crie la spoliation
sur leur demande de contribuer un peu
plus à la solidarité nationale notre
vision à nous nous défendons depuis le
début de ce texte c'est celle d'Ambroise
Croizat qui a la Libération c'était
promis que la retraite ne serait plus
l'antichambre de la mort mais un nouvel
âge de la vie vive décemment jusqu'à son
dernier souffle laissez en paix les
corps brisés par l'usure voilà la grande
conquête du XXème siècle sur laquelle
vous voulez revenir avec cette réforme
aujourd'hui c'est cela que vous voulez
sacrifier cet âge de la vie ou après
avoir consacré à au travail salarié
l'essentiel de son existence on dédit
son temps libérés à la vie familiale à
ses parents dépendants à ses enfants à
ses petits-enfants à la vie associative
culturelle sportive caritative à la vie
démocratique qui est essentielle à la
vie de nos pays c'est ça que vous voulez
supprimer
le 518 n'est pas défendu le 567 n'est
pas défendu le 579 monsieur Redon
sarrazi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre avec vous et votre gouvernement
la suppression des régimes spéciaux
c'est de la justice sociale mais dans
quelle vision le milieu du travail
êtes-vous avez-vous donc pour la justice
sociale pour vous elle passe
systématiquement par un alignement par
le bas certains régimes spéciaux
sont des régimes autonomes qui trouvent
leur équilibre dans des niveaux de
contribution ou de cotisation
délibérément plus élevées que la moyenne
dans le par le choix donc des
partenaires d'autres dans des secteurs
d'activité bien spécifiques résultats de
conquêtes sociales validées d'ailleurs à
l'époque par des exécutifs de votre
majorité
et ça a été répété à plusieurs reprises
ils sont liés à la prise en compte de
conditions particulières d'exercice du
métier la pénibilité les risques
professionnels le fait que le travail
puisse altérer les capacités physiques
et morales privées des travailleurs et
les travailleurs d'années de vie en
bonne santé ou d'années de vie trop
court vous vous en moquez donc plutôt
qu'une mesure dogmatique posez-vous les
bonnes questions
merci le 666 madame le héros
merci monsieur le Président donc cette
amendement que nous proposons vise à ne
pas supprimer des régimes spéciaux de
retraite visé par l'article premier à
savoir ceux des industries électriques
et gazières de la RATP de la Banque de
France du CESU des notaires et des
Clermont de notaire il n'est pas inutile
de répéter que ces résumes spéciaux ont
été créés pour mieux compenser la
pénibilité des métiers qui sont exercés
en 2019 les retraités recevant une
pension de régime spéciaux représentait
seulement 6% environ de l'ensemble des
retraités en les supprimant le
gouvernement va mécaniquement faire
intégrer les nouveaux travailleurs de
ces régimes dans le droit commun c'est à
dire le régime général et donc sans
compensation suffisante de la pénibilité
mettre fin au régime spéciaux c'est une
diversion comme cela a déjà été dit pour
faire oublier la confiscation par le
gouvernement de deux années de retraite
pour tous les Français ne nous laissons
pas berner une vraie mesure de justice
sociale et d'équité aurait été
d'appliquer les mesures de prise en
compte de la pénibilité à tous les
travailleurs et travailleuses
accomplissant des travaux pénibles en
2027 en 2017 pardon vous avez supprimé
le critère de pénibilité en échange
d'offrir un suivi médical personnalisé
au travail aux travailleurs concernés
mais qu'en est-il du suivi médical il
s'agit de constater les effets de la
pénibilité constater qu'après un dur
travail les salariés sont cassés ceux
qui travaillent dans nos industries
agroalimentaires ce qui accompagne nos
aînés ceux qui construisent nos maisons
nos routes ceux qui nous transportent
matin midi et soir ne veulent pas que
l'on mesure les effets de leur travail
sur leur santé ils le ressentent tous
les jours et le mesure en se levant tous
les matins ce qu'il demande c'est le
respect de leur métier le respect de
leur personne c'est de prévenir leurs
douleurs que l'on travaille sur les
facteurs de pénibilité or la santé au
travail n'est pas à la hauteur de leurs
attentes et la prévention au travail
n'est pas prise en compte sérieusement
merci le 726 n'est pas défendu le 808
monsieur Jacquin
avec plaisir monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre c'est un moment
vise à supprimer cet article car c'est
très forme des retraites est injuste
injustifié et une opportune elle
rencontre l'opposition de la majorité
des Françaises et Français la
suppression des régimes spéciaux en
aucun cas une mesure même de résorber
les problématiques de financement du
système de retraite dans le corps a
démontré qu'il n'était pas au bord du
groupe qu'on voudrait le faire le faire
croire le gouvernement cet article 1
entend supprimer les régimes dit
spéciaux qui sont le résultat de lutte
et de conquête sociale obtenue par les
salariés et leur organisation syndicale
représentative dans certains secteurs
d'activités pour faire valoir les
conditions particulières j'en ai parlé
mais difficile voire pénible d'exercices
alors où les secteurs concernés sont
pour plusieurs d'entre eux en manque
d'agent ou de salariés la mise en cause
des régimes spécifiques de retraite
renforcera cette carence 4000 emplois
non pourvu pour les chauffeurs de card
d'Île-de-France cela est
particulièrement important dans le
domaine des transports qui rencontrent
des problèmes de recrutement très
important qui contribuent à l'embolie de
nombre de réseaux ainsi plutôt que des
magies logiquement tout supprimer le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre serait
mieux inspiré de retirer sa réforme
reprend de véritables négociations avec
les partenaires sociaux étudier
profession par profession l'opportunité
de revenir intégralement ou en partie
sur certains régimes 10 spéciaux une
bonne réforme des retraites est une
réforme qui a dit sauvegarde de la
répartition et Progrès Social
pagistigmatise certains qui montrent les
Français les uns contre les autres je
vous remercie et le 821 n'est pas
défendu le 861 n'est pas défendu le 896
monsieur Lurel
et oui monsieur Lurel
merci Monsieur le
nous demandons à supprimer cet article
les arguments présentés par les uns et
les autres me semble être suffisant pour
que je m'appelle sentie sur d'autres
motifs monsieur le ministre vous avez
voulu bien voulu des clarer que
un régime spécial devrait se suffire à
lui-même et que ne se référer à autre
chose qu'à ses clients ou à ses agents
et quand donc un cas on ne pourrait
faire appel à l'impôt au contribuable
j'avoue que cet argument m'interpelle
parce que si on n'utilise plus l'utilité
sociale des activités si vous allez et
vous pousser cet argument et bien on
devrait supprimer tous les services
publics de dire que chez les usagers qui
devraient tout financer que le régime
par répartition et cette conception
restrictive qui m'interpelle malgré le
fait que on sait depuis longtemps que il
y a une part de sub vention une part
d'impôts et c'est normal parce que ça
relève de lucidité de l'utilité sociale
le travail c'est ça et cette conception
de la valeur travail même le capital
c'est du travail mort accumulé comme les
salariés c'est du travail vivant et
payent des impôts et bien sûr travail là
les équipements leur capital devrait
également payer des impôts et donc
contribuer à la solidarité nationale
merci le 941 monsieur Cardon
il est pas là bon alors il tombe le 980
c'est le président rénal
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues je vais faire
un peu une intervention qui me revient
d'une certaine façon Escal qualité parce
que je ne suis pas sûr qu'ici beaucoup
de parlementaires évoquerait le sujet de
la Banque de France alors en tant que
président de la commission des finances
je me dois quand même de dire quelques
mots sur la suppression de ce régime
juste évoqué qu'il s'agit là vraiment
d'une mesure qui
touche 10000 un peu moins de 10000
salariés ou un peu plus de 10000
salariés nous sommes vraiment sur
quelque chose de très limité que ce
régime est totalement aligné avec celui
de la fonction publique en terme d'âge
de départ comme de durée de cotisation
que les versions les pensions versées au
retraités Banque de France n'ont jamais
rien coûté à l'État par contre l'État a
reçu très régulièrement des excédents de
couverture des engagements de retraite
par solidarité avec le régime général il
semblerait que ce soit plus de 1
milliard à ce jour enfin les flux futurs
de pension sont déjà totalement et
intégralement couverts alors quoi quelle
est la logique à la suppression de ce
régime autonome si ce n'est et c'est
toujours très dangereux d'aller sur ce
terrain moral une supposée exemplarité
et je voudrais vous dire mes chers
collègues quand même que c'est une façon
extraordinaire qu'à l'état de remercier
les salariés d'une institution la Banque
de France qui part sa politique
monétaire très conciliante ces dernières
années à protéger le budget de l'État
qui aujourd'hui
cherche à les punir je vous remercie
c'est monsieur le Président le 1008
n'est pas défendu le 1029 madame Jourda
pas défendu le 1059 monsieur Houlgate
il est plus là le 1075 monsieur Tissot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
lignée de nos précédentes interventions
le présentement visa logique vise à
logiquement supprimer cet article
premier issu de longue luxe sociale
menées par les salariés du privé et du
public ces régimes spéciaux ont été
conçus pour être adaptés à des
professions exerçantes dans des
conditions particulières de travail et
très souvent difficiles et pénible au
quotidien avec mes collègues du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
nous considérons que la suppression des
régimes spéciaux listés dans cet article
sous couvert d'un prétexte d'équité
n'est qu'une diversion pour faire
oublier que tout le monde a bâtir du
report de l'âge légal du départ à la
retraite en effet comme plusieurs autres
amendements que nous présenterons sur
cet article 1 nous mettrons en avant
qu'une grande partie des régimes
spéciaux bloqués ici sont bien souvent
accidentaires et proviennent souvent à
d'autres cotisations bien plus élevées
que la moyenne du régime général vouloir
présenter comme des mauvais élèves des
professions qui ont fait le choix et
cela depuis des décennies de surcotiser
et quand même une orientation étonnante
ou un qui défendent qui dit défendre le
budget de la Nation à l'euro près
monsieur le ministre il est temps
d'écouter et de comprendre les
spécificités de ses professions il est
temps d'écouter les difficultés
quotidiennes des salariés des industries
électriques et gazières sur lesquels
nous devons compter pour rebâtir notre
souveraineté énergétique il est temps de
comprendre les spécificités des régimes
des salariés de la Banque de France des
notaires éclaire et des salariés du ces
hommes il est grand temps de prendre
correctement en compte la pénibilité le
stress quotidien de l'environnement du
travail et les horaires atypiques des
salariés de la RATP pour toutes ces
raisons mes chers collègues supprimeront
cet article premier qui n'est rien
d'autre qu'un retour en arrière je vous
remercie merci exactement 11h30 sur
l'antenne de public c'est nous sommes en
direct et nous suivons et bien une série
une centaine d'amendements de
suppression venue de la gauche
sénatoriale en clair c'est sénateur et
sénatrice réclament d'enlever de la
réforme des retraites l'article 1 cet
article qui supprime cinq régimes
spéciaux dont celui de la RATP les des
entreprises du gaz électricité ou encore
les clercs de notaire Mathias sarez
depuis 9h35 il y a donc eu des dizaines
de prises de parole et maintenant tous
ces amendements venus de la gauche on
insiste quand même à ce qu'on peut dire
être un quasimonologue de cette gauche
natale et d'ailleurs ce silence de la
droite de l'hémicycle ça agace c'est
sénateur n'est-ce pas il y a absolument
Quentin je ne pense pas me tromper en
vous disant que plus de 90% du temps de
parole ce matin est attribué à la gauche
un mutisme de la majorité dénoncés par
le communiste Pierre Laurent lors d'un
rappel au règlement en disant je cite
est-ce que les LR estime avec leur
attitude participer aux travaux du Sénat
hier déjà le socialiste Yann chanterelle
accusait la droite de l'hémicycle de
porter ce qu'il appelle le Bayon
Retailleau en réalité derrière ce
mutisme quentin se cache une stratégie
celle de ne pas rallonger les débats
avec le 12 souhait que l'intégralité de
la loi soit votée ici dans l'hémicycle
voilà deux stratégies très différentes
on comprend entre la gauche et le
matériel et la droite retour dans
l'hémistice là
forcément fini par imprimer dans la tête
des Français et c'est tellement facile
de désigner à la VAN dicte des Français
le voisin que l'on croise tous les jours
qui est peut-être un petit peu plus
chanceux que soi que le très fortuné qui
bénéficie de beaucoup plus avantages
mais qu'on croise pas parce qu'il vit
pas avec nous et je vais vous dire c'est
tellement ancré dans la tête des
citoyens que même quand vous supprimez
des régimes spéciaux ils le savent pas
parce que pour la SNCF personne n'a
encore compris merci
le 1205 n'est pas défendu le 1238 madame
jasmin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'amélioration continue de la
qualité de vie et des conditions de
travail nécessite que par équité et afin
de ne pas déstabiliser les professions
et les entreprises concernées de
supprimer cet article en effet la
suppression de ce régime spéciaux dans
le cadre de cet article du projet de loi
interroge alors que nous devons créer
les conditions de la cohésion sociale
impliqués davantage les partenaires
sociaux et valoriser de façon urgente
d'ailleurs les travailleurs l'existence
des régimes spéciaux est toujours
justifiée par les différentes
contraintes particulières et spécifiques
à chacun de ces métiers rendre
attractive ces filières c'est aussi
notre devoir vous avez supprimé les
CHSCT et vous les déshumaniser les
entreprises et les métiers il faut
supprimer cet article
inutile et injuste
merci le 1268 monsieur Montauger merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues
monsieur le ministre par cet article
vous comptez donc mettre fin à 5 des
régimes spéciaux que notre système de
retraite permet actuellement il
constitue selon vous le dépense exagérée
qui ne serait plus soutenable par notre
système de retraite en réalité vous le
savez les dépenses liées au régime
spéciaux de mes contenus à proportion
des recettes totales de cotisations
sociales et plus encore ces régimes
permettent à des secteurs et à des
cadres d'emploi de rester attractif là
où une main d'oeuvre essentielle peine à
être trouvé je pense particulièrement au
régime de la RATP il a été évoqué où les
possibilités de départ anticipées
bénéficie à ceux qui font vivre ce
service public essentiel des conducteurs
des agents de station des personnels
chargés de la maintenance des voies etc
non monsieur le ministre le départ
anticipé de ces personnes n'est ni un
privilège hérité de l'ancien monde ni
une dépense exagérée au vu de la
nécessité de ces métiers et de leur
pénibilité et si les économies réalisées
par la chaîne ces régimes sont pour vous
essentiels c'est avant tout pour leur
caractère symbolique
d'éradications méthodiques des statuts
en général et de cela en particulier
depuis 2017 malgré une hausse sans
précédentes des revenus de placement
financier vous refusez d'augmenter la
CSG sur les revenus du capital vous avez
permis à des foyers aussi très aisés de
profiter de déductibilité et de
dégrèvement de cotisations par
l'installation de la flat taxe et je ne
reviens pas sur la prospérité
outrancière de CMA CGN que vous
sanctuarisez ou que vous entendez
sanctuarisez plus encore monsieur le
ministre au-delà des Français concernés
par les régimes spéciaux les Français ne
veulent pas de votre réforme écoutez-les
314 madame prévils merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues tout le problème est là c'est
parce que
léger c'est parce qu'il a été renoncé à
améliorer les conditions de travail
c'est parce qu'il n'a même pas été
envisagé de prévoir d'autres
financements en lien avec la nouvelle
donne de la société contemporaine et je
pense comme mes collègues au profit
exorbitants très peu taxé par ailleurs
notamment que nous en sommes là cette
réforme est injus socialement les
régimes spéciaux c'était de tenir compte
de la dureté du travail et j'emploie à
dessin ce mot dureté et non pas
pénibilité et tout simplement les
risques notamment psychosociaux sont
peut-être encore davantage prégnant que
par le passé les amplitudes horaires les
pénibilités perdurent il n'y a pas de
régime de faveur il y a juste la prise
en compte de cette dureté qui abîme oui
tous ceux qui font le même travail
doivent avoir les mêmes droits les
meilleurs donc puisque nous sommes pour
le progrès social
c'est tout le questionnement du bonheur
différé que constitue la retraite ces
régimes spéciaux sont en quelque sorte
une compensation de ce qui n'a pas été
pensé en amont comment demander de
travailler plus longtemps de dans de
telles conditions qui restent dures et
comme le dit le philosophe denimaillard
avant tout droit à la retraite des
travailleurs demandent aujourd'hui un
droit de retrait de la comédie inhumaine
du travail en effet puisque tout ce
travail n'a pas été fait de repenser le
travail parce qu'on a été d'une certaine
manière paresseux oubliés aveugle aux
évolutions rapides de la société défaire
ce qui existe en rien proposé c'est une
régression et ça n'est pas acceptable
donc avec mes collègues nous proposons
la suppression de cet article mettant
fin au 5 régimes très bien 1338 monsieur
Marie
merci monsieur le président
si certains régimes sont dit spéciaux ce
n’ont pas qu'ils seraient le lieu de
privilège mais parce qu'il fonctionne
sur la base d'une solidarité restreinte
à une profession comme pour les marins
les militaires ou à une entreprise comme
la RATP qui ont pris en compte certaines
formes de pénibilité de leur travailleur
aurait atypique fréquence des astreintes
usure physique entre autres est-ce à
dire que ces travailleurs ont été choyés
privilégiés c'est l'inverse en réalité
ce sont les travailleurs du régime
général qui trop souvent sont délaissés
et défavorisés au regard de l'évolution
des modes de production toujours plus
astreignants pour preuve la
sous-déclaration croissante des
accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles
écoutez à cet égard ce que dit la Cour
des comptes qui a récemment alerté sur
la sinistralité hors norme dans certains
secteurs notamment les métiers du soin
et du lien qui nécessiterait des mesures
spécifiques en réalité les régimes
spéciaux étaient précurseurs d'une juste
appréhension du travail et de ses effets
sur les travailleurs les régimes
spéciaux ont veillé à maintenir
l'équilibre nécessaire entre la vie au
travail et la vie à la retraite en bonne
santé et l'objectif serait d'aligner le
régime général sur ces régimes spéciaux
pour prendre en considération la
spécificité des différents métiers et
non l'inverse j'ajouterai qu'il est tout
de même extraordinaire de supprimer des
acquis sociaux
issus pour bon nombre d'accord obtenu en
45 juste après la libération dans un
projet de loi de finances sur la
sécurité sociale rectificatif sans
dialogue sans négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux sans même longs
d'une compensation vous appelez ça
l'équité pour moi moins avantage et deux
ans de plus c'est de la brutalité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
supprimer cet article merci le
1371 n'est pas défendu le 1404 monsieur
le testeur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre tout à l'heure vous avez fait
allusion un ancien président de la
commission des lois comme nous sommes
deux à pouvoir nous prévaloir de cette
fonction dans cette émission j'ai cru
comprendre que ça s'adressait à moi je
pense avoir bien compris
alors je voulais vous dire Monsieur le
Ministre que
François Hollande
a décidé un jour de rendre public les
avis du Conseil d'État je crois que vous
avez une certaine connaissance de
Monsieur François Hollande et qu'à cette
époque-là d'ailleurs vous partagiez
beaucoup de choses avec lui
et
donc je ne comprends pas votre
argumentation
parce que le Conseil d'État je ne vais
pas vous l'apprendre à deux fonctions
c'est un juge et c'est le conseiller du
gouvernement d'ailleurs il y a une
grande littérature sur la compatibilité
entre ces deux missions en tant que
conseiller du gouvernement si bien ce
dont il s'agit ici le Conseil d'État
donne de bons conseils au gouvernement
et je suppose que dans la note dont il
est question il a fait état de
d'appréciation judicieuse
et je ne vois pas en quoi le fait
pour le gouvernement donc pour vous
monsieur le ministre de décider de
partager largement ces appréciations
seraient contraire à la séparation des
pouvoirs ça le serait si vous étiez
contraint de le faire mais vous n'êtes
pas contraint de le faire vous avez la
possibilité de le faire donc de vous
renouvelons cette demande conformément
une jurisprudence que vous avez
certainement partagé par le passé j'en
suis surtout Thomas je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
bien
allez monsieur le testeur vous profitez
aussi de ma générosité on peut pas dire
que soit l'amendement allez le 1434
monsieur Kerrouche oui oui oui monsieur
Kerrou va défendu
le 1502
madame filleul oui pardon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
supprimant ou plutôt en fermant madame
la rapporteur 5 des régimes spéciaux
vous divisez pour mieux régner voilà la
stratégie vous opposez les Français vous
les divisez les régimes spéciaux ne
constituent en aucun cas un privilège ni
une grâce en l'état c'est une
compensation un acquis une histoire en
tout cas nul générosité ici nul dépense
exagérées vous parlez d'un système qui
serait inégalitaire oui mais
certainement pas dans le sens que vous
lui donnez car les métiers sont
inégalitaires dans leur rapport au corps
aux esprits à leur dureté par rapport au
corps et aux esprits les ouvriers
n'ont-ils pas une espérance de vie
inférieure à
6,4 ans par rapport au cadre pourquoi
n'aurait-il pas le droit de percevoir
aussi longtemps que les autres
catégories professionnelles la retraite
leur retraite celle pour laquelle ils
ont cotisé toute leur vie oui cette
réforme au lieu de réparer les
inégalités au travail les accentueux
nous devons permettre aux travailleurs
de partir à la retraite au moment où
leur corps n'est pas usé nous leur
devons malheureusement pour votre
rhétorique est aussi immuable faire
porter au travailleur le poids de votre
réforme comptable ce qui souffre déjà
aujourd'hui dans leur chair souffriront
d'autant plus demain ce sera l'inégalité
dans la souffrance et pour comble vous
simulez une concertation avec les
organisations syndicales sans jamais
tenir compte de leur demande de leur
proposition mais tout dialogue absent et
bien vous le paierez et vous le paierez
cher dans la rue aussi je vous invite à
retirer cette réforme des
le 1541 n'est pas défendu le 1579 n'est
pas défendu le 1590 n'est pas défendu le
1620 madame pomirol ah bah rien c'est
vous qui avez déposé
merci monsieur le Président
des privilégiés le mont est lâché telle
est la vision dogmatique que votre
gouvernement semble avoir des personnes
affiliées à un régime spécial de
retraite je rappelle quand même que les
premiers régimes spéciaux ont été mis en
place par l'État en 1673 est concernait
les marins et au fil des siècles
différents régimes spéciaux de retraite
ont été mis en place et ils ont été
conservés par le CNR au monde de la
création de notre système actuel de la
sécurité sociale ils sont le résultat de
lutte social cela a été dit menée par
des salariés les organisations
syndicales de certaines secteurs
d'activité en reconnaissance des
conditions particulières pénible
d'exercices de leur travail la mesure
que vous proposez est donc une véritable
mesure de régression sociale comme était
déjà une mesure de régression en 2017 la
suppression des
critères de pénibilité pardon le
gouvernement justifie la suppression des
régimes spéciaux par une volonté
d'équité mais c'est surtout pour diviser
les salariés on sait bien depuis
Machiavel divisé pour mur régner c'est
la bonne solution à outre vous faites un
choix arbitraire à la carte entre les
régimes spéciaux qui seront supprimés
par cette réforme et ceux qui sont en
conservés et alors que plusieurs
secteurs concernent les partis de manque
de personnel la mise en place la mise en
cause des régimes spécifiques de
retraite ne fera qu'aggraver le manque
d'attractivité et des pénuries de
personnel aussi plutôt que de défendre
un système de retraite adapté à la
réalité de métier et notamment à leur
pénibilité le gouvernement choisi de
détruire ses droits qui et ainsi
niveler les retraites par le bas c'est
pour ça que nous demandons la
suppression de cet article
et le 1650 n'est pas défendu le 1662 non
plus le 1691 monsieur Leconte
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a un peu moins de trois
ans nous avons vu
ce que nous avons appelé à cette époque
les premiers de corvées les personnes
dont le travail n'était pas
télétravables et qui ont tenu le pays
beaucoup de ce qui sont visés
d'activités qui sont visées par la
suppression de ces régimes était parmi
les personnes qui n'avaient pas la
possibilité de télétravailler et qui ont
tenu le pays dans les transports publics
dans l'énergie en particulier alors
madame la rapporteur je trouve que
opposer les uns aux autres exacerber les
alougies les jalousies entre les les
droits aux pensions n'est pas convenable
le premier principe de la République
c'est c'est de travailler à la cohésion
nationale et à la solidarité nationale
et pas d'expliquer aux uns qui doivent
perdre parce que les autres ont moins ce
n'est pas logique de faire de cette
manière je veux bien croire
que les évolutions technologiques font
évoluer les pénibilités elles existent
elles ne sont pas les mêmes qu'il y a 60
ans mais elles doivent être pris en
compte et pour qu'elles soient pris en
compte il faut être crédible pas avoir
supprimé il y a 5 ans une liste de
critères de pénibilité pour le régime
général et aujourd'hui vouloir supprimer
les régimes les
certains régimes spéciaux ce n'est pas
convenable surtout lorsqu'on sait que en
ce qui concerne les transports
collectifs
il y a à la fois des métiers en tension
et en même temps avoir des personnels
qui sont correctement respectés et
correctement assuré c'est aussi une
question de sécurité pour l'ensemble des
usagers quand on sait que pour ce qui
est de l'énergie il en va de l'avenir de
notre pays et que nous avons besoin au
contraire d'élargir ces régimes à tous
ceux qui travaillent en particulier en
matière de sous-traitance et je voudrais
dire aussi parce que j'ai parlé des
premiers de merci monsieur le professeur
51 amendements identiques deux minutes
et deux minutes
allez le 1748 n'est pas défendu le 1789
n'est pas défendu je passe au 1817 du
président Cannet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
curieux ambiance encore une fois ce
matin
vous savez c'est comme dans un match de
foot parfois on regarde les équipes en
fonction du temps de la maîtrise de
balle
manifestement il y a une partie
qui
je sais pas s'il y aura des tirs au but
j'espère s'il y aura des buts on verra
bien plus tard mais en tout cas
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas à mes chers
collègues à venir et bien animé c'est
débats finalement moins pour nous que
pour les Français qui nous regardent et
qui attendent de nos débats des
clarifications politiques
mes chers collègues finalement ces
amendements de suppression multiple
vise en fait à nous donner un peu le
sens sur le mot de réforme et j'ai
retrouvé une phrase assez célèbre
d'ailleurs de d'un ancien Premier
ministre anglais du 19e siècle très
célèbre Benjamin d'israéli qui était
d'ailleurs un conservateur et qui disait
réformer ce qu'il faut conserver ce
qu'il faut réformer ce qu'il faut
conserver ce qui vaut et bien oui il
faut conserver quand les choses vont
plutôt bien et qu'elles ne posent pas de
problème majeurs ces régimes spéciaux
vous le savez c'est ce sont les
pionniers de notre régime de retraite
générale il correspond à une histoire
mais il correspond aussi à un actuel et
un devenir pour beaucoup de de salariés
ce sont des conquêtes sociales qu'il
faut préserver donc nous ne voulons pas
nous associer à l'opération de
démolition sociale qui est la vôtre dans
beaucoup de ces articles monsieur le
ministre soutenu par la droite
sénatoriale et donc à mon tour je
demande la suppression de cet article
merci si je peux me permettre monsieur
le Président Kanner juste une petite
parenthèse Benjamin d'israëly a perdu le
pouvoir parce qu'il maltraitait la
Chambre des communes il a perdu au
profit de Gladstone donc attention
peut-être sur les je dis ça je dis rien
amendement en 1990 madame la Présidente
du 7 mars date du mouvement social parce
que c'est ça en réalité ce dont vous ne
voulez pas c'est que votre amendement
sur les régimes spéciaux et leur
suppression soit discutés avant le
mouvement du 7 mars mais ce qui était
étonnant parce que vous êtes tellement
sûr de vous sur le fait que les Français
détesteraient tellement tous tous les
régimes spéciaux que vous ayez une
immense à adhésion dans ce cas-là
soumettez le hautement c'est amendement
avec l'article sur les régimes spéciaux
peut-être même les Français vous
soutiendront peut-être même vous
déclencherez une manifestation aussi de
soutien votre amendement de suppression
des régimes spéciaux donc une grande
manifestation peut être autant de gens
dans la rue pour votre amendement qu'il
y en a contre cette réforme donc
l'amendement sur les régimes spéciaux
devraient être là il n'est pas là nous
voterons donc à cet instant la
suppression de l'article 1 avec nos
amendements
voilà il est 11h52 sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat nous sommes toujours en
direct pour suivre l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites et nous sommes au
milieu de l'examen d'une longue série
d'amendements de suppression de
l'article 1 il y en a plus de 300
identiques qui ont été déposés par la
gauche et on a regroupé comme ça 50
avant le moment de suppression qui sont
examinés dans la même série c'est les
bars on se dit qu'ils sont très écoutés
notamment par les premiers intéressés
Mathias sarez vous êtes toujours en
tribune de presse rappelez-nous ce qu'il
y a dans cet article 1 et bien cet
article 1 c'est un gros morceau puisque
c'est l'article qui ouvre le volet des
recettes ils vise à supprimer les
régimes spéciaux 5 au total mais
lesquels et bien ceux de la RATP des
salariés des industries du gaz de
l'électricité ou encore ceux d'éclairs
de notaire des salariés de la Banque de
France ou encore celui du Conseil
économique social et environnemental un
article qui tient particulièrement à
cœur à la droite sénatoriale qui
accélérer ces suppressions en allant
même plus loin que ce que propose le
gouvernement les LR du Palais du
Luxembourg souhaitant supprimer cette
clause du grand-père c'est ce que vient
de dire la sénatrice Laurence Rossignol
c'est un point de désaccord notamment
avec leurs alliés de la majorité les
Alliés centristes un débat qui trouve de
l'écho dans l'actualité vous l'avez dit
Quentin puisquière les syndicats des
électriciens et gaziers ont annoncé
entamé une grève reconductible pour
coller au calendrier de l'examen de cet
article au Sénat Fabien gay le sénateur
communiste il y a d'ailleurs fait
référence tout à l'heure merci Mathias
pour toutes ces remarques et on entend
aussi cet agacement de la part des
sénateurs de la gauche et qui regrettent
le silence de la droite sénatoriale dans
ce débat retournant l'hémicycle du
nombre d'accidents de travail trop
souvent corollaire avec celle de
l'activité économique ainsi au-delà des
atteintes physiques et mentales des
salariés il convient de s'interroger
profondément sur les conditions et les
organisations du travail il est grand
temps de réduire le temps de travail
prescrit et de revenir à la retraite à
60 ans car si comme vous j'accorde une
grande importance à l'emploi et au
travail celle-ci ne doit pas se faire au
détriment de la santé des travailleurs
je vous remercie
merci je vais donc passer à la
Commission à gouvernement je demande à
la Commission et au gouvernement parce
que j'ai bien entendu le rappel au
règlement du président rénal de ne
procéder à aucune interpellation vous
répondez globalement sur les amendements
vous n'interpellez personne qui répond
pour la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
oui simplement merci monsieur le
président
de la liberté de parole que vous donnez
au rapporteur
nous y serons très vigilants mais je
crois que
nous continuerons comme ça rappelait que
effectivement dans les interventions
j'ai noté que beaucoup parlaient des
acquis sociaux a été très attachés aux
acquis sociaux ce que l'on comprend bien
et qu'il faut file du temps ils ont
parfois été remises en cause on a déjà
augmenté la durée de travail puisque
elle avait été à un moment à 60 ans elle
est passée à 62 ans et puis les
gouvernements se sont succédés elle n'a
jamais été remise en cause personne
jusqu'à présent
n'a souhaité
à travers ses actions gouvernementales
reprend de ces mesures là
deuxièmement en ce qui concerne cette
fermeture des régimes spéciaux
effectivement l'accélération de la
convergence n'est pas à l'article 1
l'article 1 c'est la fermeture au
nouveau entrants des régimes spéciaux la
convergence c'est une accélération de
l'âge c'est donc l'article 7 qui parle
des
âges et c'est une dépense c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
trouvé pour cet amendement de passage
dans l'article 1 puisqu'il relève de
l'article 7 vous en conviendrez j'ai
bien compris également que il y avait
dans vos interventions une
interpellation par rapport aux
inégalités de traitement
prise en compte notamment dans le cadre
de la pénibilité là aussi la Commission
a pensé qu'il fallait essayer de gommer
toutes ces inégalités puisque un
chauffeur de bus puisque ça a été
réalité s'il travaille au sein de la
RATP n'a pas la même prise en compte de
sa pénibilité qu'un chauffeur de bus
d'un régime
du service public ou s'il est dans le
privé puisque les facteurs de pénibilité
qui s'activent sont différents puisque
dans le public c'est des certificatifs
donc entre les services actifs les super
actifs il y a des possibilités de
convergence vous souhaitez aller
pardon pardon monsieur le Président
certains certains souhaitent aller vers
une réduction des inégalités allant vers
la prise en compte de ceux qui ont par
exemple un âge plus bas
ça a été rappelé par le monsieur le
ministre une dégradation des comptes
publics qu'il faut aider régimes de
retraite qu'il faut alors combler pour
combler un régime par répartition ça
veut dire que en contrepartie soit on
augmente l'âge de durée de ceux qui ne
sont pas en pénibilité donc à travers
cela on peut supposer que les autres qui
ne sont pas considérés dans ces
secteurs-là doivent travailler plus
longtemps ou alors ou alors on fait
appel à l'impôt à l'impôt mais je
rappelle je rappelle que notre système
est un système contributif fondé sur 80%
des recettes sont les cotisations des
salariés 20% au titre de la solidarité
qui permet de redistribuer un certain
nombre de de c'est un élément de justice
sociale
plus vous augmentez la part des impôts
dans un système par répartition plus
vous le remettez en cause vous le
remettez en cause pardon c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous n'avons pas choisi ce
dispositif là car que nous n'avons pas
remis en cause le système par
répartition voilà la position de la
Commission qui fait que elle a donné
notamment des avis défavorables mais
Elisabeth Doisneau vous le précisera
merci
[Applaudissements]
madame l'arboratoire général la vie de
la commission est défavorable sur
l'ensemble de ses amendements je voulais
juste rappeler que la fermeture du
risque vieillesse donc de certains
régimes spéciaux ne ferment pas
l'ensemble des autres risques comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure mais ça répond à
des enjeux de lisibilité
d'équité et de confiance surtout dans le
système de retraite par répartition et
nous le voyons bien quand on regarde de
les sondages vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de
la population que la jeunesse n'a
absolument pas confiance dans notre
système actuellement ils ont été créés
provisoirement ça a été aussi dit tout à
l'heure par l'ordonnance du 4 octobre
1945 c'est important de le dire ils ont
été maintenus jusqu'à ce jour pas pour
tous je rappelle que la caisse des mines
par exemple enfin en tout cas sur
l'aspect vieillesse a été voilà ramené
au régime général ça a été pareil pour
la SNCF et
nous avons parlé
j'ai entendu parler de il y avait aucune
urgence mais franchement quand on vous
propose justement la clause du
grand-père il n'y a aucune urgence c'est
quand même quelque chose qui qui viendra
très très doucement si on peut dire et
on peut comprendre que d'autres
propositions vont vont se vont vont être
proposés alors ils ont été créés
provisoirement et je voudrais dire que
la poursuite de ce mouvement elle répond
aussi à un enjeu d'équité entre les
assurés car ces règles dérogatoires
peinent de plus en plus à être justifié
par des critères objectifs et là encore
vous avez donné par vos témoignages
effectivement qu'il y avait pas
un regard par branche ou par métier qui
n'était pas suffisamment équitable pour
l'ensemble de des assurés elle permet
aussi parce que vous avez parlé de la
fluidité du marché du travail je pense
que ça permettra davantage de fluidifier
le marché du travail en réduisant
justement la complexité du système et la
variation des droits sociaux selon le
régime d'affiliation enfin je voudrais
dire comme la annoncé tout à l'heure le
ministre c'est que l'affiliation au
régime d'assurance vieillesse de droit
commun se traduira par la possibilité de
bénéficier du compte professionnel de
prévention pour la prise en compte des
effets de l'exposition à certains
risques professionnels c'est donc une
avancée qui pourra se compléter
également par des dispositifs
conventionnels d'entreprises ou de
branches sur le modèle de la SNCF et
nous les avons reçus en audition et ils
nous ont fait part justement de ces
progrès qu'ils ont pu voir se mettre en
place par rapport à la pénibilité de
certains métiers merci c'est donc à
notre développement monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président je vais être
relativement bref puisque la défense des
amendements de suppression et c'est
assez logique a largement repris les
arguments qui ont été développés dans la
discussion générale sur l'article
peut-être ajouter trois précisions une
pour faire équation générale la
fermeture de l'affiliation des nouveaux
embauchés au régime général de
l'assurance vieillesse permettra comme
cela a été dit aux nouveaux embauchez
bien évidemment ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans le cas des régions spéciaux pas
nécessairement aussi automatiquement de
bénéficier des défauts des dispositifs
du C2P ainsi des nouveaux dispositifs
que nous proposons sur des critères
ergonomiques la deuxième chose que je
soulignais cela transparaissait dans un
certain nombre de débats concerne la
soutenabilité et la solidité financière
des régimes spéciaux puisque parfois il
y a des inquiétudes exprimées sur le
fait que la fermeture du flux puisse
amener une difficulté en termes de
financement des retraites actuels
d'abord bon nombre de régimes ont une
capacité à faire face à cette nécessité
de financement et par ailleurs comme
nous l'avons fait sur pour la SNCF nous
veillerons à garantir la soutenabilité
ce y compris au travers des futurs
textes financiers et notamment des
futurs PNSS troisième remarque enfin
je pense que dans le champ lexical
retenu par les intervenants pour
défendre les amendements souvent sont
apparus les mots de privilégier les mots
d'inégalités ce n'est pas le champ
lexical du gouvernement nous considérons
que la fermeture des régimes spéciaux et
donc cette harmonisation d'une question
d'équité nous ne parlons pas de
privilégier nous savons que ces régimes
ont été construits dans le temps et que
celles et ceux qui en bénéficient
bénéficient d'une situation qu'ils n'ont
pas nécessairement construite mais à
laquelle ils ont adhéré au moment où ils
signaient un contrat de travail par
contre le seul argument de l'équipe
financier ou de la nécessité d'une
subvention ne suffit pas à ne pas
suffisant c'est un élément majeur pour
des régimes qui pour beaucoup d'entre
eux sont déséquilibrés mais la question
de l'équité et de l'harmonisation des
règles tant de cotisations que de
déroulement de carrière et d'accès en
termes d'âge au départ de la retraite et
la seconde raison tout aussi importante
qui nous pousse à la fermeture en flux
des régions spéciaux donc pour ces
différentes raisons la vie du
gouvernement est bien évidemment
défavorable sur les amendements de
suppression merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons passer aux explications de
vote j'ai déjà une batterie de demande
je précise tout de suite que j'ai aussi
en parallèle une demande d'explication
de scrutin public merci de vous y
préparer monsieur lévrier
et bien allez monsieur lévrier monsieur
le Président je prends la parole déjà
pour répondre ce matin à quelques
quelques commentaires me demandant
pourquoi j'étais là puisque je ne
parlais jamais et simplement parce que
j'ai un sens de la controverse qui veut
que avant tout je préfère écouter que de
parler dans tous les sens
et quand je dis et quand je dis écoutez
vous voyez je ne coupe jamais la parole
aux autres en règle générale enfin et
donc objets vous écouter je vais
reprendre en espérant d'être exhaustif
tout ce que vous avez pu dire qui
concerne exclusivement la suppression
des régimes spéciaux de retraite vous
nous expliquer que ce sont des régimes
pionniers et qu'ils font les premiers à
prendre en compte la pénibilité que ce
sont des métiers en tension soit par
manque d'agence soit pour des raisons
d'accidentologie et non de remplacement
des agents arrêtés que sont des régimes
équilibrés voire excédentaires que faire
cette réforme augmente les difficultés
de recrutement vous pensez que cet
article cherche à diviser les
travailleurs et à faire passer ces
régimes spéciaux en bouc émissaire qu'on
veut pousser à croire que ces agents
sont des privilégiés qu'il remet en
cause le contrat social cherche à
niveler par le bas et aussi est une
diversion pour faire oublier les autres
articles voilà j'ai essayé de résumer ce
que vous avez dit en 2h30 il me reste 37
secondes les réponses ont été données
clairement et par les rapporteurs et par
le ministre je partage ses réponses mais
voilà il m'a fallu une minute j'espère
que je n'ai rien oublié je vous remercie
monsieur Breuillet
ah oui
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègue à l'équité je comprends que les
actionnaires de notre pays qui viennent
d'encaisser 59,8 milliards jusqu'
scandaleux les avantages des chauffeurs
de bus de la RATP dont les conditions de
travail sont si favorables que
l'employeur ne parvient pas à recruter
ou encore les avantages inouï des clairs
de nos terres d'ailleurs pas tous les
actionnaires je pense surtout au 0,1%
des Français qui touchent les deux tiers
de ces dividendes soit 40 milliards en
2022 40 milliards quand vous en cherchez
13 pour équilibrer ce système d'ailleurs
200 millionnaires issus de 13 pays
demande aux dirigeants du monde entier à
être davantage taxé pour la France selon
Roxane taxé nos milliardaires à hauteur
de 2% permettrait de financer le déficit
prétendument hors de contrôle des
retraites via le
FFR judicieusement créé par Lionel
Jospin pour faire face aux papy boom
si c'était trop douloureux de nombreux
bénévoles jeunes retraités des Restos du
cœur pourraient accueillir ces
milliardaires trop taxés mais ça
permettrait d'économiser deux ans de vie
enfin puisqu'il me reste quelques
instants je voudrais dire je ne
comprends pas en revanche comment des
sénateurs peuvent défendre au nom de
l'équité de clôturer les régimes
spéciaux j'ai bien dit clôturer des
chauffeurs de bus et des clercs de
notaire et s'extraire eux-mêmes de cette
réflexion en ne voyant pas que pour les
Français puisqu'on a évoqué un
référendum notre régime autonome ne
relève pas de les quitter si d'ailleurs
nous faisions un référendum j'ai peur
que des vents mauvaises souffrent sur
notre assemblée monsieur le ministre la
démarche la demande de publicité de la
note de synthèse du Conseil d'État nous
avons un jeune président qui veut
bouleverser et rénover la démocratie et
finalement il fait du Richelieu il
maintient le secret et il ref use de
diffuser cette note qui éclairait les
Français merci Madame linman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la conséquence de notre rapport triste
qui veut un référendum suggère un
référendum sur les régimes spéciaux
pensant peut-être le gagner et le refuge
sur l'ensemble de cette réforme en
particulier sur les le passage 64 ans
massivement refusé par les Français
je ne crois plus que les Français soient
obnubilés par les régimes spéciaux
pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont bien compris que
c'était à travers ce démantèlement et
des statues et des régimes spéciaux la
poursuite de la dégradation massive des
conditions du salariat dans ce pays avec
la précarité avec
nous sommes à des pays où les Français
les salariés considèrent qu'ils sont les
moins bien considérés les moins bien
traités que les conditions de travail
sont mauvaises pourquoi
essayez au régime
déficitaire de certains régimes spéciaux
on a tellement externalisé on a
tellement soustraité on a tellement à
travers cette sous-traitance cette
finition
précariser le travail
baisser les salaires réduit les
avantages sociaux et on a tué l'idée que
une entreprise c'est une communauté
humaine
dans lequel les uns et les autres sont
solidarisés à travers un statut à
travers des garanties à travers de la
protection sociale et puisque vous
parlez d'équité quelle équipe il y a
aujourd'hui entre un salarié d'une
grande entreprise
et le salarié du sous-traitant de énième
rang de cette entreprise aucune celui
qu'elle sous-traitant mal payée
précarisé je ne dis pas que des
avantages madame briquet vous n'avez
plus la parole madame liemann madame
briquet
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues cela a
été dit les régimes 10 spéciaux ne sont
pas le lieu de concentration de
privilèges privilège desquels les
cotisants du régime général serait
injustement exclue
c'est ce que le gouvernement s'est
vertus pourtant a laissé croire pour
donner un semblant de justice à sa
réforme aussi injuste inutile
quel curieuse idée de la justice que de
vouloir fermer des régimes qui prennent
en compte des contraintes particulières
et la pénibilité de certaines
professions il en est ainsi ça cela a
été largement dit pour les industries
électriques et gazières mais pour les
autres aussi la justice serait plutôt de
s'en inspirer car ce sont les
travailleurs du régime général qui sont
depuis trop longtemps délaissés au
regard de l'évolution des modes de
production
ces régimes spéciaux sont donc
précurseurs d'une juste appréhension du
travail et de ses effets sur les
travailleurs
mais votre idée de la justice n'est pas
du mieux pour tous mais bien de
s'assurer d'une régression sociale
collective monsieur le ministre cette
réforme va à l'encontre va
contre-courant les Françaises et les
Français le 7 mars prochain vous le
démontreront
merci monsieur le Président je voterai
évidemment ces amendements de
suppression de l'article 1 pour des
raisons de fond notamment parce que
Madame la rapporteur vous semblait
penser que s'ils ont eu lieu d'être
comme la pénibilité au travail est un
phénomène du XIXe siècle qui n'existe
absolument plus il n'aurait plus de
raison de l'être aujourd'hui je rappelle
que par exemple des salariés qui font
les 3 à 8 dans nos centrales nucléaires
ont une espérance de vie moindre que
d'autres salariés je rappelle aussi pour
les autres salariés des IEG qui ne
partent pas par anticipation qu'ils
partent en moyenne à 62,9 ans qui est
exactement l'âge de départ moyen en
France vous parlez d'équité la voici
ensuite je suis surprise parce que
souvent ici nous avons des débats sur la
différenciation c'est à dire la
possibilité de tenir compte des réalités
différentes et d'avoir des politiques
publiques qui en tiennent or là je
trouve qu'un certain nombre d'entre vous
sont dans la recherche d'un égalitarisme
parfait que je ne m'explique pas qui ne
tient compte ni des difficultés de
recrutement ni de la réalité encore une
fois de la pénibilité enfin Madame la
rapporteur vous évoquez les chauffeurs
de bus qui ne seraient pas sous le
régime de la RATP bien oui ouvrons le
débat nous disons depuis le début nous
considérons que ce sont des régimes
pionniers qui ont donc vocation assez
élargir à d'autres catégories de
salariés ouvrons ce débat et enfin une
raison qui paraît peut-être moins de
fond mais qui n'en est pas moins
importantes pouvez-vous nous expliquer
quel est l'effet direct sur les recettes
les dépenses de la sécurité sociale en
2023 qui est l'objet même de
plfssr de la fermeture de ces régimes
spéciaux dont vous avez dit monsieur le
rapporteur vous-même que la fermeture ne
s'adresserait qu'aux nouveaux entrants
et donc par définition ça n'a absolument
aucun impact sur les recettes et les
dépenses de 2023 ça n'a donc rien à
faire dans ce plfs
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les régimes
spéciaux ont été créés grâce à des
quêtes sociales cela a déjà été dit dans
le cas de négociation et c'est une juste
compensation des conditions de travail
difficiles de perspective de carrière et
d'évolution de salaire parfois plus
limitée qu'ailleurs aujourd'hui à
nouveau c'est la stigmatisation des
régimes spéciaux de ceux qui auraient
soi-disant des avantages exorbitants on
évoque sur certains bancs l'équité pour
justifier cette nouvelle régression on
cherche surtout à faire quelques
économies de bout de chandelles sur le
dos des travailleurs et de faire
diversion pour mieux masquer l'injustice
de votre allongement d'une durée du
travail vous cherchez surtout à opposer
les Français les uns aux autres pour
justifier cette réforme vous évoquez le
coût de ces régimes cela reflète la
philosophie de votre réforme une réforme
paramétrique destinée à faire des
économies car votre problème c'est bien
les déficits et la dette que vous avez
en supprimant l'ISF en refusant de
trouver des ressources nouvelles en
taxant notamment les super profits un
très bon rapport de nos collègues
communistes avaient démontré que
l'évasion fiscale optimisation fiscale
coûtait entre 30 et 36 milliards au
minimum à l'état voire même 50 si l'on
prend certains critères et on voit bien
que les économies que l'on cherche à
faire sur les régimes
spéciaux sur l'ensemble des retraités
sont sans commune mesure avec les
ressources dont on se surprise prive
pour réduire nos déficits cette réforme
et cette volonté de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux démontrent l'esprit de
cette start-up nation ou on décore
certes discrètement un champion de
l'optimisation fiscale et en même temps
stigmatise ceux qui travaillent on
abaisse leurs droits c'est la réforme de
l'injustice et c'est acharnement sur les
régimes spéciaux le démontre monsieur
gay
monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je suis en
désaccord avec mon collègue Martin
lévrier moi je crois que toutes les
questions n'ont pas obtenu de réponse
j'en ai j'en ai deux trois par exemple
on parle beaucoup d'égalité d'équité
pour vous et c'est un débat les régimes
spéciaux c'est horrible et il faut en
finir il faut mettre tout le monde au
même niveau vous l'aurez compris ce
n'est pas notre choix mais moi par
exemple je voudrais comprendre les
critères qu'on procédé pour savoir ce
qu'on allait fermer éteindre ou cassé ou
ceux qu'on allait sauvegarder pourquoi
on s'attaque à la RATP aux IOG au
notaire et à la Banque de France et pas
l'Opéra de Paris à la Comédie française
aux marins pêcheurs aux avocats et aux
professions libérales le seul ministre
là on vous pose la question pourquoi
quels critères deuxième chose
on vous l'a déjà dit sur le
commentaire
merci monsieur le Président le statut
coûtera plus cher vous le savez
aujourd'hui lorsque un salarié rentre
par exemple dans le statut il passe en
contrat mais la nation il sait qu'il
partira plutôt il a un statut qu'il
protège en même temps il accepte d'être
moins payé que dans le privé et à faire
des jours des nuits
365 jours par an c'est ça la question et
casser le statut ça voudra dire qu'il va
falloir payer beaucoup plus cher parce
qu'autrement vous aurez un problème
d'attractivité et donc là on vous repose
la question comment vous allez faire sur
les IOG mais par exemple comment vous
allez faire à la RATP le grand mal de la
RATP c'est qui manque des milliers de
chauffeurs on vous l'a dit et sachez que
cette année il y a plus de 300 personnes
qui sont même pas passé par la case DRH
ils ont abandonné leur poste c'est ça
aujourd'hui la réalité et c'est la même
chose chez les chemin ots on vous
l'avait dit en 2018 vous verrez on aura
du mal à recruter et c'est déjà le cas
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
c'est Monsieur savolder
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Miss mes chers collègues depuis que
j'assiste comme tout le monde ici à
cette séance j'ai trouvé que c'est vrai
que le silence peut être parfois le plus
cruel des mensonges
et le cilet et oui et oui et oui et oui
le silence peut être le plus cruel des
mensonges et parce que ça vient d'être
dit là on va prendre la question des
transports il faut il faut il faut
s'expliquer silence et silence complice
avec le ministre c'est vrai que monsieur
dussa vous avez été extrêmement bref
donc c'est un silence complice auquel on
assiste et le débat contraint sur le
régime spéciaux il faut dire la vérité
aux françaises et aux Français je vais
prendre l'Île-de-France c'est quoi le
sujet des régimes spéciaux pour quand on
parle de RATP des cheminots c'est pas
les régimes spéciaux c'est pas les
privilèges c'est qu'on met en
concurrence les RATP avec Keolis et
Transdev que vous proposez au bachillis
de la RATP au cheminot de prendre un sac
à dos social voilà c'est les routards du
malheur vous leur proposez d'aller
travailler dans le privé en cassant tous
les statuts les statues c'est la
garantie du service public voilà l'enjeu
de la question et quand vous c'est pas
les régimes spéciaux c'est pas ça le
sujet
c'est vous êtes en train de livrer la
France point et malliée à des intérêts
étrangers parce que quand vous prenez
Transdev par exemple en Île-de-France ou
Keolis vous donnez un des principales
investisseurs qui ont un capitaliste
allemand le moyen de s'investir et de
rentrer sur le marché du transport
français voilà la question voilà la
vérité donc vous êtes dans un silence
qui est cruel et qui mensonges et devant
les Français qui manifestent ont
tellement d'inquiétudes l'inflation les
retraites les deux hommes que vous
voulez leur mettre de travaux forcés
vous êtes depuis deux jours incapable de
vous inscrire à débattre avec vos
arguments et votre projet de société
j'avoue que le Parlement est en
difficulté à cause de vous allez bon
les explications de vote c'est pas ça du
tout alors merci d'en rester à des
explications de vote ça franchement non
franchement vous ne respectez pas le
règlement monsieur le Président Laurent
vous devriez le respecter le premier
moi rien ne me dérange monsieur ça va le
délit mais je demande à ce que le
règlement du Sénat soit respecté et vous
le respecterez comme tout le monde non
non madame la Présidente après les
explications de vote
monsieur ça vole délit
monsieur ça vole d'Élie ne m'obligez pas
à utiliser les articles du règlement qui
sont plus sévères
je peux
monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président nous sommes
sur un débat qui est absolument
essentiel et il est très concret est-ce
que nous sommes là pour résoudre des
problèmes qui existent dans le pays ou
pour les aggraver parce que nous parlons
de plusieurs régimes spéciaux et
notamment de celui de la RATP
quel est l'un des principaux problèmes
que nous rencontrons aujourd'hui dans le
pays c'est la crise dans les transports
publics et en particulier dans les
transports en Île-de-France et quelle
est l'une des grandes difficultés que
nous avons c'est une difficulté
financière et c'est une difficulté de
recrutement lorsque dans les lois
financières il y a des injustices que
nous dénonçons vous nous répondez oui
certes c'est injuste mais il faut penser
à l'attractivité et bien là il y a un
enjeu d'attractivité est-ce que nous
allons relancer l'attractivité des
métiers de la RATP et notamment des
machinistes des conducteurs de bus en
supprimant pardon en fermant le régime
spécial de la RATP non nous allons
aggraver le problème dont nous savons
qu'il est tient d'abord à l'attractivité
des métiers et dans
ressembler nous avons déjà refusé
d'augmenter le versement mobilité des
entreprises pour financer les transports
publics en Île-de-France nous avons déjà
refusé d'augmenter comme il l'aurait dû
comme cela aurait dû l'être la
participation financière de l'État et
aujourd'hui nous serions je crois bien
inspirés de refuser aussi alors de
supprimer le régime spécial de la RATP
parce que nous allons aggraver un
problème que nous devrions plutôt
résoudre celui des transports publics de
l'attractivité de ces métiers et des
conditions de travail de ces personnels
merci président Laurent
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président
dans les réponses qui nous ont été
faites on a entendu beaucoup le mot de
convergence mais en matière de droit
social la convergence toute l'histoire
du droit social le monte la convergence
c'est la généralisation progressive des
dispositions les plus protectrices ça
n'a jamais été le contraire en matière
de temps de travail en matière de congés
payés en matière de pénibilité en
matière de droit des femmes en ce moment
à chaque fois qu'on fait progresser le
droit social c'est parce qu'on
généralise une disposition plus
protectrice que les précédentes vous
nous proposez exactement le contraire et
vous nous dites ça va faire de la
convergence mais s'il y avait réellement
un débat de convergence au sens du droit
social qui s'était ouvert mais les
syndicats auraient été les premiers à
être d'accord pour participer à cette
discussion c'est parce qu'elle a été
refusée qu'ils sont tous opposés à la
réforme aujourd'hui et en matière de
pénibilité vous allez vers la
suppression de tous les régimes
collectifs en vérité de toutes les
garanties collectives vous voulez
individualiser ce droit c'est ça la
réalité et vous supprimez les régimes
spéciaux justement parce qu'ils montrent
des possibilités de garantie collectifs
pour des professions et c'est ça en
vérité que vous voulez supprimer mais
avec ça je le répète après mes collègues
précédemment nous allons vers des
pénuries d'effectifs dramatiques dans
des secteurs stratégiques et en
Île-de-France à propos des transports et
de la RATP quand les transports publics
ne marcheront pas pendant les Jeux
olympiques de l'année prochaine vous
serez les premiers à verser des larmes
de crocodile sur l'image de la France
dans le monde entier
voilà on le voit à la gauche ce matériel
qui multiplié les dépôts d'amendement et
maintenant les explications de vote sur
ces amendements tout cela on le comprend
c'est que la gauche et bien utilise
toutes les armes parlementaires
ont-elles dispose dans le règlement du
Sénat pour se faire entendre et donc
aussi un des facto pour ralentir
l'examen de la femme de retraite sauf
que c'est sénateur de gauche des fois et
bien ils investivent d'autres sénateurs
alors qu'ils sont en explication de vote
et ça ça n'est pas permis par le
règlement et donc on a entendu Roger
caoutchi qui a menacé d'utiliser
certains articles de ce règlement pour
contraindre davantage elle est débat
c'est des articles qui sont permis par
exemple par l'article 38 qui limite à un
orateur pour un orateur compte sur un
amendement donc que pour l'instant cette
menace n'a pas été mis en effet mais on
l'a entendu dans les propos de Roger
caroutchi un mot avec vous Mathias il a
été question tout à l'heure dans ces
débats sur et bien les régimes de
l'article 7 l'article 7 c'est celui sur
la mesure d'âge le report de 62 à 64 ans
de l'âge de départ à la retraite alors
que nous en sommes sur l'article 1 sur
les régimes spéciaux pourquoi y a-t-il
eu ces références vous avez raison
Quentin il est important de distinguer
ces deux articles alors l'article 1
celui qui nous intéresse au moment où on
se parle ouvre le volet des recettes
vous l'avez dit c'est la suppression des
régimes spéciaux on les rappelle celui
de la RATP des salariés des industries
du gaz et de l'électricité celui des
clairs de notaire des salariés de la
Banque de France ou encore celui des
salariés du Conseil économique social et
environnemental ça c'est pour l'article
1 l'article 7 quant à lui fait partie du
volley des dépenses il ouvre d'ailleurs
même et concerne la mesure du de report
de l'âge de départ à 64 ans en plus de
l'accélération de la durée d'assurance
si on parle de cet article ce matin
c'est que la droite sénatoriale a décidé
de placer des amendements visant à
accélérer la des régimes spéciaux
notamment en supprimant cette clause du
grand-père après cet article 7 c'est un
amendement qui a été déposé d'ailleurs
par le président du groupe LR Bruno
Retailleau une stratégie dénoncée par la
gauche comme l'a expliqué la sénatrice
de l'Oise Laurence Rossignol je cite
vous ne voulez pas que votre amendement
soit discuté avant le 7 mars elle se
réfère là à l'importante journée de
mobilisation qui est annoncée ce jour-là
Laurence Rossignol qui va même plus loin
puisqu'elle a expliqué au LR qu'ils
avaient peur que cet amendement à lui
seul provoque une mobilisation aussi
importante que la loi complète merci
Mathias pour toutes ces explications et
donc il y a cette obstruction cordiale
de la gauche qui dépose beaucoup
d'amendements mais qui est très
respectueuse et en fois on voit aussi ce
reproche maintenant de la gauche envers
la droite une forme d'obstruction
passive car la droite ne prend pas la
parole dans ce débat et donc nous sommes
toujours dans les explications de vote
autour
d'amendement de suppression de l'article
1 sur la suppression des régimes
spéciaux et il y aura ensuite dans
quelques minutes sans doute inscrit un
public 2023 mais on sent quand même une
certaine prudence
et il n'y a pas de date limite trop trop
proche non plus
j'écoute les rapporteurs madame Doineau
dit mais de toute façon ne vous
inquiétez pas comme dirait votre ami
d'armanin ça va bien se passer puisque
ça va être très lent faisons un
référence à la clause du grand-père et
Monsieur Savary aussi donc je n'y
comprends plus rien et ce que vous êtes
pour la fermeture des régimes spéciaux
maintenant est-ce que vous êtes pour la
fermeture des régimes sociaux plus tard
est-ce que vous êtes pour que ce soit
anticipé ce que vous voterez
l'amendement tout à l'heure bref donc je
vous fais une proposition je voterai la
suppression de cet article je vous
conseille de faire de même parce que
autrement vous allez vous même avoir la
tête qui tourne
monsieur Joly
ministre Michel collec mon explication
de vote également défendre les régimes
spéciaux de retraite fait partie de la
lutte contre une forme de régression
sociale inspirée par une philosophie
néolibérale qui prétend ici aujourd'hui
agir au nom de l'égalité ça nous a été
dit la suppression proposée vise en
réalité un aliment vers le bas et au
final à la destruction de ce qui peut
être qualifié comme un droit visant à
plus de justice sociale
il faut plutôt voir ces régimes spéciaux
comme des modèles ils ont servi le point
d'appui ça a été dit à la mise en place
d'une couverture vieilliée généralisée
on peut encore aujourd'hui s'en inspirer
pour continuer à améliorer le régime
général d'assurance vieillesse notamment
par la prise en compte des spécificités
des différents métiers dont la nature
évolue et la pénibilité également je
voterai donc que l'amendement visant à
maintenir cette ces régimes spéciaux je
vous remercie monsieur Chantrel
[Applaudissements]
donc merci monsieur le président
comme l'ensemble de mes collègues sur
ses bancs je peux que constater déplorer
effectivement si j'ose me permettre le
silence de cathédrale sur les bancs de
la droite je vois que votre bâillon
monsieur Retailleau est vraiment
solidement attaché sur les
parlementaires de votre groupe
vous pratiquez finalement quel est ce
que je pourrais appeler l'occlusion
parlementaire incapable de défendre une
réforme dont vous êtes pourtant les
co-auteurs
mais j'ai relevé quand même un propos du
rapporteur écoutez vous allez voir vous
allez pas être déçu j'ai relevé j'ai
relevé un propos du rapporteur Savary
particulièrement scandaleux et éclairant
pour nos débats sur votre brutalité
vis-à-vis des plus démunis alors vous
avez dit je cite sur les métiers
pénibles plus on met en exergue la
brutalité de ces métiers moins on
trouvera de nouveaux entrants vous vous
rendez compte de ce que vous avez dit je
répète plus on met en exergue la
brutalité de ces métiers
[Applaudissements]
et voilà Monsieur Madame Ferrer
deux fois bon moi Madame Ferret on verra
après madame Ferrer
alors ça va pas exagéré
madame Ferrer vous avez la parole
explication de vote sur cet amendement
rappelant que ces régimes spéciaux ce
n'est pas qu'il serait le lieu de
privilège mais bien parce qu'il
représente l'héritage de régime
fonctionnant sur la base d'une
solidarité interprofessionnelle ou
propre à une entreprise ces régimes
prévoient des règles de départ à la
retraite spécifique car ils prennent en
compte une pénibilité une pénibilité
spécifique des travailleurs qui cotisent
qu'il s'agisse des horaires atypiques de
la fréquence des astreintes ou de
l'usure physique notamment en
raccrochant ces régimes spéciaux au
régime général le gouvernement prévoit
donc pour l'ensemble des nouveaux
entrants alors on se parle dans ces
régimes le départ à la retraite à 64 ans
avec 43 annuités sans que les mesures de
prise en compte de pénibilité
intrinsèque à ces métiers soit
suffisante et là je veux faire le lien
avec l'article 9 l'article 9 qui ne
évoqué comme son nom Dick ou son numéro
l'indique que un peu plus tard or nous
évoquons dès l'article premier cette
remise en cause des régimes spéciaux
sans avoir donc discuté de cette
question de pénibilité mais l'article 9
et dénommé prévention et réparation de
l'usure professionnelle je préfère
utiliser le mot de pénibilité par
ailleurs évidemment et je l'ai dit je
sais que je voterai pour ces amendements
de suppression sur cette ces régimes
spéciaux mais je vous le redis mes chers
collègues en face de nous il aurait été
extrêmement intéressant et constructif
d'entendre vos interventions sur
connaître votre point de vue sur ces
amendements de suppression sur cette
remise en question de ces régimes
spéciaux or là encore je considère que
le débat est tronqué puisque nous ne
connaissons pas votre point de vue sur
ces amendements
[Musique]
merci j'ai toujours pas compris madame
prévil vous demandez la parole ou pas
non bon alors madame la Présidente
Rossignol je ne sais pas
non plus bon monsieur Jacquin non mais
bon on me donne des listes et on me dit
ils ont demandé la parole mais si vous
l'avez pas demandé très bien monsieur
Jacquin alors allez-y
merci monsieur le Président je vais me
permettre de revenir sur les propos
partiels de Madame la rapporteur mais
auparavant je voulais saluer les propos
de Pascal Savoldelli ce qu'il a dit sur
la RATP et sur le fait qu'on joue un
second on est dans les prolongations le
silence de la majorité et éloquent
effectivement et je me rappelle le
nouveau pacte ferroviaire en 2018 où
vous avez voté pour l'ouverture à la
concurrence nous sommes vraiment dans
les conséquences avec cette suppression
des régimes spéciaux les difficultés de
recrutement de Keolis notamment sur des
des chauffeurs de bus en Île-de-France
c'est véritablement une véritable vérité
qui a été rappelée par Pascal symbole
Delhi donc j'en viens madame la
rapporteur a une partie de vos propos
lorsque vous si j'ai bien compris vous
avez dit dans votre explication que
une partie des régimes spéciaux ont été
créés temporairement en 1945 et devait
être supprimé d'ailleurs 1 a été
supprimé celui des mineurs alors je
tiens à vous préciser madame la
rapporteur que il n'y a plus de mineur
en France raison pour laquelle le ce
régime a été supprimé précision il reste
une mine de sel en France dans notre
département de Meurthe-et-Moselle
ou des mineurs descendent encore au fond
tous les jours à 400 mètres pour
travailler je vous invite madame la
rapporteur et peut-être monsieur le
ministre aussi
à visiter cette mine d'ailleurs on peut
à 400 mètres de fond il y a un système
touristique qui fait qu'on peut prendre
un repas nous pourrions déjeuner au fond
et découvrir ce régime particulier des
mineurs de sel et j'invite d'ailleurs
mon collègue j'en prends soin Husson
et ben on peut y aller ensemble et
peut-être avec monsieur le Président
karucci aussi mais si
c'est pas immédiat
allez merci Monsieur Jacquin monsieur de
allez monsieur douceur merci monsieur le
Président on a eu très peu
d'explications convaincantes sur la
place de cet article dans ce texte la
rapporteur nous l'a dit il n'y a pas
d'urgence à la fermeture de ces régimes
on revient donc au débat qu'on avait
hier sur l'architecture législative le
véhicule législatif de de ce texte et et
on ne comprend pas bien qu'elle était
l'urgence à rectifier notre PLFSS un
mois après son son vote ici sur cette
question spécifique et des régimes
spéciaux alors on devine maintenant
pourquoi vous vous entêtez à garder
confidentiel cette note du Conseil
d'État ça tient certainement à la
fragilité de la place de cet article
dans le texte alors tout à l'heure j'ai
parlé de la paresse voir de la torpeur
qui avait gagné les rangs de la majorité
sénatoriale
mais on pourrait parler aussi de la
vôtre monsieur le ministre puisque vous
êtes issu de la gauche mais vous avez
rapidement glissé vos pas dans les
pantoufles du sarkozyme et de la
Recherche fainéante du bouquet mystère
et donc contre le nivellement par le bas
et contre la case du service public nous
demandons la suppression et nous
voterons la suppression de cet article
oui merci merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président
je voulais d'abord moi-même remercier
Monsieur lévrier parce que c'est vrai
que depuis ce matin et depuis
l'ouverture de cette séance c'est la
seule personne qui a pris la parole sur
cette partie de l'hémicycle et je pense
que c'est assez révélateur assez
troublant sur cette obstruction
silencieuse qui est en train de
s'installer
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est ce qui vous agace
monsieur le Président mais en tout cas
le sens de l'humour me ravi l'âme mais
allez-y président
parce que on est à un moment quand même
important sur cet article 1 sur ces
fameux régimes spéciaux je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est un petit peu les
choses qui reviennent à chaque à chaque
réforme on veut s'attaquer à ces assez
régime spéciaux mais on a besoin
effectivement de s'éclairer donc on a eu
beaucoup d'arguments est-ce que je note
c'est que des arguments très différents
et moi j'aimerais bien avoir parce que
quand j'entends madame la rapporteur
vous nous avez dit qu'effectivement il y
avait pas forcément
urgence à revenir justement sur la
clause grand-père on a monsieur
rataillod qui on va voir après l'article
[Musique]
[Rires]
le président Retailleau qui qui propose
un amendement après après l'article 7 et
qui n'est pas anodin puisque ça viendra
et ça et ça changera en fait en tout cas
la nature de cet article cet article 1
j'aimerais à la fois effectivement avoir
ben ouais ou des explications par
rapport à cet amendement et par rapport
à est-ce qu'il y a urgence est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas urgence et puis surtout
j'aimerais avoir la vie des ministres
parce que ça c'est quand même important
la vie des ministres tout je crois que
c'était hier soir on a des ministres qui
nous ont donné la vie sur des
amendements qui s'était déjà pas encore
passé je pense qu'on pourrait avoir un
avis sur cet amendement du président
retaillou qui nous éclairait justement
pour le mettre c'est le Président
gantard Monsieur Marie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
je crois que nous devrions
collectivement nous inquiéter d'une
tendance de fond qui n'a pas dû vous
échapper et qui fait d'ailleurs l'objet
d'un certain nombre de publications
tendance de fond qui touche
particulièrement la jeunesse qui
manifeste un détachement de plus en plus
important à l'égard de leur intérêt pour
le travail relayant celui-ci loin
derrière leur souhait de profiter de
leur temps libre et de moments qu'il
considère plus épanouissant cette
tendance est une des raisons du désamour
des Français
loin d'être la seule mais une des
raisons pour bon nombre de métiers qui
apparaissent à tort ou à raison peut
être actif et qui se traduit par des
tensions extrêmes sur certains d'entre
eux
parmi les plus difficiles restauration
entretien bâtiment transport énergie et
d'autres si vous ajoutez à ce contexte
la remise en cause d'un certain nombre
d'acquis sociaux le refus d'augmenter le
SMIC et de convoquer une grande
conférence sur les salaires si vous
ajoutez à cela la perte de pouvoir
d'achat et bien travailler pour beaucoup
pour paraphraser Henri Salvador ce n'est
plus la santé et le message que vous
leur adressez c'est que la pénibilité
n'existe pas que ceux qui bénéficient
d'une prise en compte de celle-ci au
travers de leur régime de retraite vont
perdre ce qu'il n'était pas un avantage
mais une juste prise en compte de leur
engagement professionnel mais ce si l'on
veut réhabiliter le travail répondre aux
tensions dans un certain nombre de
métiers ce n'est pas en alignant vers le
bas les acquis sociaux que l'on y
arrivera c'est la raison pour laquelle
il faut maintenir ces cinq régimes diss
spéciaux et surtout engager des
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux sur la pénibilité mot qui a été
rayé de ce projet de loi et ne fait
l'objet de rien article monsieur Lurel
j'aimerais faire monsieur le Président
rappelle au Règlement sur la base de
l'article 36 à Linéa 5
[Musique]
sinon je vous demande de m'inviter à
venir me produire à la tribune aligné à
5 pardon
si vous refusez cette explication je
viens je vais à la tribune mais vous
faites votre explication
de sa place
peut l'inviter à monter à la tribu j'ai
du mal à interpréter ce texte j'aimerais
aller à la tribune ou m'exprimer est-ce
que vous m'interdisez de monter à la
tribune non non vous intervenez de votre
place comme tous les orateurs précédents
monsieur Lurel je vous en prie encore
votre explication de votre vous avez
déjà utilisé
d'interprétation dans la faire je
devrais pouvoir monter à la tribune mais
oui
vous refusez de m'éviter mais je
pourrais 50 secondes mon plaisir monté à
la tribune
bon ben enfin bref on dira que c'est de
l'obstruction mais c'est l'arme du
parlementaire démuni gérer le temps
déposer
la deuxième chose je reprends ce que
notre collègue Laurence Rossignol a dit
il y a un moment
les ministres n'ont pas répondu la
majorité parlementaire et sénatoriale ne
répond pas il y a de lames dans cette
affaire cette première on vote un peu à
l'aveugle la deuxième c'est de dire bien
on va
accélérer la mise en extinction
fermeture ou mise en extinction
c'est-à-dire la mort accélérée de ces
régimes là on aimerait avoir une
explication d'ici et vous êtes avant
2025 tous ces régimes et j'ai même cru
entendre le président retaille au dire
vous comprenez on attendra pas 43 ans
pour la mise à mort de ses régimes on
aimerait une explication pour éclairer
le vote
monsieur Lecomte vous n'avez pas demandé
la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bon
fondamentalement il y a une partie qui
n'est pas une surprise le gouvernement a
supprimé les critères de pénibilité en
2017 par ordonnance et maintenant il
veut supprimer
plusieurs de régimes spéciaux qui
prennent en compte cette pénibilité bon
d'une certaine manière c'est logique ce
n'est pas la nôtre mais c'est la leur la
logique du gouvernement par contre
lorsque nous vous interrogeons sur
l'avenir des services publics
sur la capacité de recruter pour les
services publics en particulier dans les
services publics de transport ou dans
les transports d'une manière générale
lorsque nous vous interrogeons sur
l'avenir de l'ensemble de notre secteur
énergétique
les EDF mais aussi l'ensemble de la
sous-traitance dans les domaines de
l'énergie qui assurant notre
souveraineté à l'avenir aucune réponse
sur notre capacité d'avoir des outils
qui permettent de répondre à
l'attractivité des métiers et au fait
qu'aujourd'hui ces métiers sont en
tension aucune réponse
alors de la part d'un ministre de
l'Emploi c'est un peu étonnant parce que
sur ces sujets c'est essentiel pour
notre pays d'avoir des réponses et nous
sommes convaincus que ces régimes
spéciaux tout en étant pas la réponse
absolue font partie des éléments qui
permettent à ces métiers d'être
un peu attractif et il mériterait plutôt
d'être élargi plutôt que d'être fermé
madame poncemonge
merci monsieur le Président alors
excusez-nous de ne nous répéter mais il
semble que vous n'entendiez pas que ces
régimes spéciaux se sont des droits
associés à la pénibilité de façon fine
et pertinente puisque cela suit la
appartenance au tableau d'exposition aux
risques et ça au fil de la carrière et
selon la pénibilité effectivement vous
avez une majoration de la durée de
service qui se traduit par une
anticipation de l'âge du départ à la
retraite c'est un dispositif donc de
départ anticipé et Monsieur le Ministre
on se réveille
vous voulez les renvoyer au C2P mais le
C2P c'est au maximum deux ans
d'anticipation hier c'était 60 ans
aujourd'hui c'est 62 ans et bien c'est
trop tard monsieur le ministre c'est
pourquoi le report de votre de votre
réforme prévoit que l'assurance maladie
va avoir un milliard de plus à débourser
pour maladies de longue durée les
catégories actives c'est ce qu'il faut
faire dans les métiers du soin et de
l'aide si vous voulez ne pas faire du
départ en inaptitude des aides et des
soignants la première cause de sortie il
faut non seulement les faire partir à 57
ans comme à l'arrête RATP mais il faut
aussi réduire leur semaine de travail et
non monsieur le rapporteur Savary il ne
suffit pas de faire silence sur la
dureté de ces métiers pour améliorer
leur attractivité dès à présent il n'y a
plus d'aide-soignante et d'aide à
domicile qui rentre dans nos services
donc la solution ce n'est pas les
exosquelettes c'est la réduction du
temps de travail c'est l'élargissement
assez branches de l'esprit et de la
méthode des services spéciaux
8 nous sommes en direct sur antenne de
publics depuis 9h30 ce matin et au
moment où je vous parle nous sommes
toujours au milieu des explications de
vote des sénateurs de gauche sur des
amendements de suppression déposés par
ces sénateurs de gauche sur l'article 1
qui concerne les régimes spéciaux et il
doit y avoir une suspension pour le
déjeuner autour de 13 heures
mes collègues d'écouter les Français il
faut absolument écouter les Français les
morts je pense qu'il faut aussi ne pas
avoir l'oreille sélective et aujourd'hui
les Français ils demandent effectivement
la suppression de ces régimes spéciaux
ils demandent de et oui ils demandent la
suppression de ces régimes spéciaux moi
je les ai entendus et les Français
et il demande aussi pourquoi est-ce
qu'un plombier pourquoi est-ce qu'un
boulanger pourquoi est-ce qu'un coiffeur
aurait moins de droit qu'un chauffeur de
la RATP à Paris et donc effectivement il
faut harmoniser il faut faire en sorte
que pour lutter contre les les iniquités
nous puissions avoir la suppression de
ces régimes spéciaux et puis je voudrais
rassurer quand même madame de La Gontrie
c'est la crise de la Gontrie non nous
n'avons pas la tête qui tourne en tout
cas pas dans la majorité présidentielle
et nous sommes plutôt cohérents c'est le
seul gouvernement qui aura fait et qui
aura eu le courage de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux mais c'est le seul
gouvernement aussi qui supprimera les
régimes spéciaux avec la clause du
grand-père et nous ne voterons pas
pardonnez-moi président Retailleau mais
nous ne voterons pas le l'amendement
Retailleau qui voudrait accélérer ce
départ et donc nous nous souhaitons
effectivement maintenir la clause du
grand-père mais tout en supprimant les
régimes spéciaux donc nous voterons
contre cet amendement ces amendements de
suppression
madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres il faut supprimer cette
article et supprimer le texte carrément
je l'ai déjà dit et je le répète la
situation est inquiétante et là non
implication des partenaires sociaux
c'est une erreur en négligeant les
salariés concernés par ces régimes
sociaux alors que les cabinets de
conseils s'engraissent régulièrement sur
les carences les défaillances et les
incohérences de votre gouvernement il
faut valoriser le travail et les
travailleurs en les protégeant davantage
et en créant les conditions
d'attractivité de ces métiers
nécessaires il faut que ces métiers
soient justement reconnu et attractif
il faut également pour le développement
économique et social que cet article
injuste est justifié soit supprimé
merci
madame la Présidente
bien entendu je vote récemment pas
simplement par souci de défendre des
régimes spéciaux mais parce que je pense
qu'il se joue autre chose dans cette
affaire on va plusieurs années que
j'observe les libéraux
s'obséder sur les régimes spéciaux et je
note plusieurs choses la première c'est
que cette obsession elle est une
obsession de la droite post-gauliste du
temps de Gaulle les régimes spéciaux
n'étaient pas un sujet on défendait le
CNR l'ordonnance de 45 sur la sécurité
sociale premièrement deuxièmement cette
obsession elle est concomitante à la
montée en puissance de la
financiarisation de l'économie et la
baisse de la répartition de la juste
répartition entre le capital et le
travail
or plus notre pays est fragmenté plus
vous incitez les gens à chercher les
responsables de leur souffrance à côté
de au plus proche d'eux en fait c'est
une méthode assez facile qui consiste à
faire croire aux salariés que s'il n'est
pas assez payé c'est à cause du chômeur
au chômeur que si les pensées indemnisés
c'est à cause de celui qui est au RSA et
Annie finit à celui qui RSA que si la
pas de travail c'est à cause de
l'immigré qui lui prend moi je suis
soucieuse de l'archipilisation comme dit
Jérôme Fourquet de l'atomisation de la
République du sentiment national
collectif que nous sommes en train de
perdre et nous le perdons pas simplement
parce que les gens perdent en identité
nationale c'est parce que le progrès
social le progrès républicain qui
faisait le ciment du sentiment national
et de la cohésion des citoyens dans la
République ceci mandat est en train de
s'effondrer et avec la suppression des
régimes spéciaux vous contribuez à
effondrer encore Dav antage ce qui fait
la République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président je ne vous laisse
surtout pas qu'on se quitte dans
quelques minutes après l'arrêt de cette
séance sans remercier les oppositions au
Sénat d'avoir cité tant de fois mon nom
et franchement je n'en attendais pas
tant et je pense que je n'en mérite pas
tant alors merci mes chers collègues
d'avoir donné un peu de notoriété au nom
que vous avez fait raisonner dans cette
émission maintenant sur le fond monsieur
le Président puisqu'il faut que je fasse
une explication de votre bien sûr nous
n'allons pas voter ses amendements et
nous voterons l'article 1 puisque nous
sommes favorables à la fermeture de ces
régimes spéciaux et nous sommes
favorables à une accélération et à une
convergence en 2040 pourquoi est-ce que
l'amendement que je présenterai tout à
l'heure a été placé en seconde partie
pas par un calcul calendaire calcule que
vous faites vous-même calcul que vous
faites vous-même c'est tout simplement
que il représente une modification du
régime de versement de prestations et
que il appartient de le placer à la
seconde partie au moment de la partie
des dépenses si nous voulons
l'extinction en tout cas la fermeture de
ces régimes spéciaux c'est précisément
lance rossignol parce que nous pensons
que ils abîment en quelque sorte le
commun il concourt à l'archipérisation
comment expliquer aux Français que pour
des mêmes travaux pour la même
pénibilité vous vous trouvez ici sur
Paris vous partez à 52 ans et vous vous
trouvez ailleurs et vous partez 10 ans
plus tard ça n'est pas compréhensible
évidemment chers Fabien gay il y a pas
de il y a pas de lien entre la
souveraineté que nous aimons que nous
voulons vous et moi promouvoir
énergétique et les régimes spéciaux
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire et sur
désormais aussi une mise au point
puisque vous nous reprochez de ne pas
participer au débat nous y participerons
pour les amendements bien entendu que
nous voulons défendre pour lesquels nous
voulons enrichir le texte simplement
il n'y a pas de silence nous nous
exprimons très régulièrement par la voix
de nous rapporteurs de nous rapporteurs
évidemment évidemment ce que je voudrais
terminer pour dire aussi que nous ne
tomberons pas dans le piège que vous
nous demandez vous voulez faire de
l'obstruction vous voulez faire de
l'ostruction et nous pas nous voulons
examiner l'ensemble du texte et donc
nous réservons notre temps de parole
pour défendre nos positions nos
propositions
madame Cohen
depuis le début de ce débat on nous
explique que cette réforme répond à des
exigences de nature budgétaire et
comptable pour rééquilibrer un système
de retraite par répartition supposément
déficitaire et pourtant il apparaît
qu'en supprimant le régime spécial de la
RATP vous allez créer un déficit
supplémentaire ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit mais Christophe rondin le directeur
de la caisse de retraite de la RATP que
nous avons auditionné à la commission
des affaires sociales le 1er février
dernier et qui donc nous a dit que la
suppression de ce régime spécial
provoquerait à partir d'octobre 2023
entre 20 et 25 millions d'euros de
déficit supplémentaires alors que les
agents sous statut continueraient de
partir à la retraite à 56 57 ans et demi
pour les personnels de catégorie A
monsieur Retailleau personne ne part à
52 ans il faut réviser votre histoire
quel impact aura alors votre réforme
monsieur le ministre un impact sur le
niveau de pension des agents de la RATP
le contribuable lui sera contraint de
compenser le déficit supplémentaire qui
s'élève à 780 millions d'euros par an
aujourd'hui avec votre réforme la note
passera à 1,2 milliards d'euros par an
d'ici 4 ans quant aux
IG pour le donc les électriciens et
gaziers
l'âge moyen de départ anticiper de 57
ans essentiellement pour les services
actifs et concernent 20% des agents
service actifs ça veut dire les plus
exposés à la pénibilité et dont le taux
de services et de 100%. donc il faut
raison garder mettre fin au régime
spéciaux sous prétexte d'équité de
supposés universalité est une diversion
pour faire oublier que tout le monde va
bâtir du report de l'âge légal la
justice sociale et l'équité serait
justement d'appliquer de telles mesures
sérieuses de prise en compte de la
pénibilité sur l'ensemble des
travailleurs qui accomplissent les
travaux pénibles plutôt que de niveler
par le bas voilà pourquoi il faut
absolument supprimer cette article
voilà on voit tes explications de vote
on voit tous ces amendements déposés par
la gauche sénatoriale la gauche qui
utilise toutes les armes du réglement du
Sénat pour s'opposer à cette réforme des
retraites mais mathiasent vous êtes en
tribune de presse c'est vrai qu'on
insiste aussi à des reproches de la part
de la gauche du fait qu'il y ait un
monologue en fait dans ces débats oui
absolument en un peu plus de trois
heures de séance on a insisté à un quasi
monopole de du temps de parole par la
gauche d'ailleurs le président du groupe
lerbe Bruno Retailleau vient d'y faire
référence il a parlé il a remercié les
oppositions d'avoir autant cité son nom
ce matin la gauche qui critique donc un
mutisme le communiste Pierre Laurent
lors d'un rappel au règlement à dit je
cite est-ce que les LR estiment avec
leur attitude participer aux travaux du
Sénat en réalité derrière ce mutisme la
gauche veut dénoncer une stratégie de la
part de la droite de ne pas rallonger
les débats avec derrière le souhait que
toute la loi ça soit votée le président
Bruno Retailleau vient d'ailleurs de
démentir cette stratégie il a assuré que
la droite prendra son temps de parole
lorsqu'elle aura à défendre des
amendements et bien merci merci Mathias
et alors que le Sénat va examiner va
voter sur tous ces amendements de
suppression nous vous donnons
rendez-vous sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat très précisément à 14h30 pour le
retour du direct autour de cette réforme
aujourd'hui quand on se promène sur le
quai du port à Marseille on voit des
immeubles des années 50 et 60
[Musique]
où est passé la ville ancienne
le quartier du port fondé par les Grecs
il y a 2600 ans